this is Jocko podcast number 142 with
echo Charles and me Jocko will Inc good
evening echo good evening
SLA Marshall could be a braggart of the
first order I could write on toilet
paper with a Koran and sell it was a
routine boast but his favorite claim to
fame was at first the most puzzling to
me and years later the most significant
in terms of unraveling the hustler and
the phony that he was and how he was
nonetheless able to make such a mark on
the US Army Slam regularly brought the
fact that the army had made him a
general despite his never having
attended even one military school and
that he was the only general in the army
to have this distinction he neglected to
say and never would have had I not
followed up out of sheer curiosity that
he'd gotten his star not in the Regular
Army but in the reserves meanwhile with
no reason not to believe him I accepted
slams story of World War one his
experiences as an infantryman in all the
major campaigns his battlefield
commission to become the youngest second
lieutenant in the US Army during the war
the romantic tale he spun of Armistice
Day when he saw in the end of the war
sharing his canteens
with his brigade commander in the
trenches with no reason not to believe
him I accepted slams tales of World War
2 to his participation in the fighting
in the Pacific as well as his service in
Europe which had him in the front line
of the Normandy invasion it would be
many many many years in which slam
repeated the stories endlessly in which
his reputation was only further
bolstered as one or the other appeared
in everything from current biography
1953 to the obituaries upon his death in
1977 and in his autobiography published
two years later before I would discover
it was all a lie slam had been an
enlisted man with the 315 engineers 90th
Infantry Division during World War one
and spent his time not fighting as an
infantryman but repairing
Road roads until just before the war's
end he had not been battlefield
commissioned and he wasn't anywhere near
the trenches on 11 November 1918 in
being instead at the army france-based
Officer Candidate School then called
infantry Candidate School the
self-proclaimed youngest lieutenant in
World War one who in fact never served
an officer in any outfit regular or
reserved in any capacity ever was not
commissioned until April 1919 long after
the last angry shots were fired
according to his service record slam saw
no infantry combat in World War two
either although he was awarded a CIB for
the Marshall Islands campaign while
serving on the DEA staff and far from
being on the ground from the earliest
hours of the 6 June 1944 Normandy
invasion slam didn't even arrive in the
European theater until July and then it
was as a staff officer slash historian
reconstructing the operation and while
slam would speak with pride of being the
only American soldier to serve in all
four of America's great wars in the 20th
century it was acclaim more than more
than a little deceptive his Korean War
experience covered exactly three months
December of 1950 to February 1951 when
he was recalled from the reserve to
active duty as a historian / operations
analysis for the 8th army a stint for
his country that produced the river and
the gauntlet for himself
and his service in Vietnam was
undertaken as a six-year retire reserve
general and a 40-year experienced
journalist slams job when he wasn't
wearing a khaki looking for a story on
the Army's tab a historian as careless
with his own history as slam marshal was
could hardly be a careful historian and
Marshall proved the rule veterans of
many of the actions he documented in his
books have complained bitterly over the
years of the inaccuracy or blatant bias
with it although the truth was that slam
was a
fallen and irrevocably smashed Idol in
my eyes he knew I'd grown away from him
throughout our time together but it was
not something to discuss I cherished my
career too much to risk getting on his
bad side and I was opportunist
opportunistic enough to see the value of
my staying on the good side but there
must have been many like me whose
silence in the face of slams power only
added to it and gave credence to his
dubious expertise who allowed him to
have an observed amount of influence
which fed his ego and lined his purse
and for years did an incalculable
horrific disservice to the army the
thing he professed to love above all not
to mention to the nation and to the men
who fought and died in Vietnam when
general Johnson had warned me take care
with slam he's he is the Army's powerful
friend but he can be a treacherous enemy
I had not understood what he meant but
when I finally did I understood too that
the chief of staff had gotten it
backwards the reality was that slam
marshal was the Army's powerful enemy
because he was its most treacherous
friend and if he were alive today
perhaps even more than the Vietnam era
generals who determine aliy maintained
we won the war we lost in their hands
slam marshal would have plenty to answer
for that right there is a section from
my favorite book about faced by colonel
david hackworth and he's talking about
his experience with a guy by the name of
SLA Marshall otherwise known as slam
slam Marshall and that's a pretty
devastating opening that's a pretty
devastating that's a pretty bad
devastating opening you can hear what
his career was so there's a lot of
negativity around SLA Marshall and for
me coming from hackworth
that's basically all I need to hear
that's all I need to hear is we know
when Hackworth you know goes and and so
Hackworth work
did it tour in Vietnam with him they
were going around documenting things and
he got to know him and at first he kind
of idolized him it'll talk about that a
little bit but and that's one of the
things that Haqq mentions in about face
was that he had this huge impact on the
army and in hack says that he used to
read his books over and over again and
and so it's kind of a weird dichotomy
there is that hack got information from
some of SLA Marshalls famous books that
he wrote about combat but then and in
but then he turned out to not have told
the truth so one of the books that he
talks about that he read a bunch is a
book called men against fire and it's
based on his interviews and reporting on
world war ii and that book made some
claims and some of the claims that the
book made are just patently untrue yes
law that are just not true and the
biggest of the lies is that right to
call it a lie the biggest of the claims
maybe it's a lie the biggest of the
untruths we'll call it that the biggest
of the untruths revolves around this
notion that SLA marshal presents that in
combat only about 15% of the soldiers on
the battlefield in combat actually fires
a weapons at all 15% now that's a really
strange thing to say now and and knowing
what I know now I think he may have done
that for a couple of reasons
and I'm not making excuses I'm saying
this is why I think he would do that
because there's no excuse for doing this
the first is I think he wanted to have a
theory or hypotheses that was like kind
of shocking and and would gain him some
publicity right that's a shocking thing
when you hear hey in combat only 15% of
people fire their weapons right you're
going what are you talking about that's
crazy
so I think he wanted to have something
to discuss that would that would bring
him out to the limelight
you know the shocking
and second I think he saw that there was
an actual problem right that maybe not
as many people shot their weapons in
combat as should and he wanted to fix
that problem so it was it 85% of the
people that weren't shooting the weapon
no but maybe the number was a decent
percentage that that didn't shoot or
could have shot more is that possible
yeah I could say that that's possible
maybe not as many people were not as
many people were shooting as you would
have liked so that's that's why I think
he got focused on that particular
subject and I think normal human life
things right I think he had a big ego
which actually I don't think he did he
had a big ego he was insecure I think he
made up some of these other stories
which which are horrible to make up
stories about your combat experience
this is a big mistake I think this is
you know in many ways this is like one
of the first documented cases of stolen
valor right and obviously I don't like
stolen valor
so there's a lot of negativity around
SLA Marshall and I have to be careful
because I it's it's very easy for me to
throw the baby out with the bathwater
right and when you you know okay so I'm
here to learn
right and despite these very very
significant character shortfalls here's
the facts the books that he wrote guided
the military and had a significant
impact on military leaders for many
years including hackworth including
Hackworth so eventually I had to look
and see what is in these books
and what if anything I could learn from
the books and I think from my
perspective okay so so he did massive
amounts of interviews with people and he
did have you know he was okay he wasn't
in d-day he was there a month later
interviewing people finding out what
happened so we talked to a lot of people
and
I think his perspective the same thing
with World War one he wasn't there but
he was close to it and he talked to a
lot of people then he spent his time in
the Pacific Theater and he spent time in
Crete so he had perspective it's not the
perspective that he claimed to have and
if he would have been smart and just
said look I wasn't on the front lines
but I talked to a lot of people I have I
was in the military I have a good
perspective here's what I've learned if
you would have said that it would have
been fine unfortunately he didn't say
that do we throw the baby out with the
bathwater the the the my initial like
gut reaction is yes liar no right right
hey no I'm not gonna listen this guy
mm-hmm but I had to think about it if
this book influenced the military so
much in this book in particular the book
is his men against fires the big book
that he wrote I say the big book it's
the book that he wrote after World War 2
I think it came out in 1947 and it's it
had a big influence and I can tell you
that it had a big influence it had a big
influence and this is what's funny it
had a big influence because despite so I
guess the facts about his career came
out after he died he died in 1977 and
the facts came out some years after that
right I would hear quotes from SLA
Marshall all the time when I was in this
guy-- is a known liar again maybe that's
a harsh word but he did not tell the
truth and you know when it comes to like
making up what you did in combat you
kind of you kind of earned yourself the
the name liar so the guy lied and yet I
would hear quotes from what he said and
what he taught and what he thought and a
lot of it made sense right so okay is it
true that a even a broken clock is Right
twice a day
that's that's still a pretty small
percentage but I'd hear quotes from from
SLA Marshall that were correct and it
wasn't a small number of quotes and so I
think despite his ego despite his lying
he had a lot of good he had gathered a
lot of good information and talked to
enough people that he actually started
to make sense and he saw people in
multiple different wars again did he see
it to the degree that he claimed to know
but you know there's there's there's a
lot of military historians that were
never in any kind of combat whatsoever
that were never even in the military
there's there's plenty of very respected
I've got books in the queue and I don't
know if I'll ever cover him but I've got
books in the queue that are great books
about war and about the military that
were written by people that were never
in the military there's military
theorists that were never in the
military that I have a great deal of
respect for so then that they say
sensible things so so is there a
question of character yes are we gonna
throw the baby out with the bathwater
I'm gonna try not to I'm gonna try and
see what we can learn and I think from
when I read this book and I read this
book a long time ago and I don't know
anyways I got stuff out of it and I
think there's actually I'm gonna tell
you I think there's actually a lot to
get out of this book and if nothing else
it reflects and reinforces some lessons
and bring some other ones that we paints
them a little bit more clearly so
without further ado and I found myself
as I was as I was reviewing this book
again that would like about halfway
through it I totally forgot that it was
this guy that I cuz they're a liar right
I got over that right because I'm
thinking that that makes sense yes that
does that and he's pointing quotes from
military leaders and yeah yeah that's
are you with me I mean does it make
sense I'm a hundred percent sense cuz
remember back in the day remember milli
vanilli remember that those that group
oh yeah yeah the two guys yes so
everyone they were liars
yeah stuff as it turns out as it turns
out but when they were all you know on
the radio and stuff but everyone liked
that you know they'd you know blame it
on the rain or whatever did they did
they recover they did not recover from
their situation negative
and I asked la marshal was dead yeah
well one of the guys committed suicide
in milli vanilli it was like you know
you got heavy but nonetheless the point
is it's like yeah it's not them singing
it you know they're liars or whatever
but the songs were kind of dope that's
so you know same deal Marshall milli
vanilli same thing same situation same
if you put on one of the Vanilli Milli
Vanilli songs right now don't bring it
right back you know to the dance or
whatever you know it's still good it's
good so you've had a lot of the guys
that actually sing it or why don't you
teach those two guys how to sing is that
our de sayin yes so one time not to go
too deep into it but they try to make it
goes to 5 milli vanilli over here into
it and they were like hey we think you
could cuz they messed up on stage right
the skipped yeah and well and so they're
like oh my god they panicked they ran
offstage all this stuff they could have
just been like yeah we were lip-synching
for that show but then I forget how they
handled it but then people were like hey
how long a guy to kill himself a long
time oh you know they got exposed all
this stuff and so they're like they're
like no we'll prove it you know and then
so the people came in and listened to
him like actually singing the thing it
was like oh my god not even close these
guys can't even sing you know it's you
you got to tell the truth about what's
going on man yeah that's the thing like
just like I said like why not just get
here the people who really sang those
songs they were older people they were
like old like 50s or something like that
like so they didn't have the pop culture
kind of feel so they were less
marketable and they just hire a couple
like vocalists I mean how bad can those
guys sing terrible oh it's the real guys
oh and yeah you can watch the little
documentary thing whatever look good and
they fit German accents - that's the
thing - yeah they're from Germany oh so
it's like it's the just night and day
they're different and but the real
people who sang it they're like like I
said like cold you know funky like kind
of jazz type people from what I remember
there is less Marco but just like how
you said sure they're less marketable
but man they're putting out some pretty
cool songs I mean yeah I mean yeah I
don't know the marketing I think that's
a big part of it I don't know man but I
mean you are right you know it's weird
it's also because the stuff that there's
stuff that sa marshal says in this book
he he's making he's making statements
that they stand on their own
you don't need you know to be able to
say look I was here so therefore what
I'm saying you should listen to like
know the the value of what you're saying
should stand on its own he don't need to
be you don't need to be I have some
certain experience you know it's like
Lafe and I talk about and I would say
you can't if you're trying to prove a
tactic to someone yeah like if I say hey
when you get in this situation here's
what you should do
I shouldn't say because this is how we
did it when I was in Baghdad and when I
was in Ramadi or whatever or when I was
in Nam my clinic no here's the tactic
and look at how it performs go and do a
trial run go and do some force-on-force
training you'll see that the tactic
works an SLA marshal smart guy great
writer god you know could have said hey
here's these tactics that I learned from
these other people that just got out and
that wasn't good that's a little easier
thing isn't it just wasn't good enough
for him didn't you guys have a name for
that once them someone bust that out
yeah yeah we weep we just when I was in
Baghdad Baghdad when I was in Baghdad we
did it like this yeah and you can't
stand you can't stand on that right is
it good to have experienced and say hey
look when I was in Baghdad this is how
we did it perhaps we should try it this
way
that's one thing but to say when I was
in Baghdad this is how we did it so
that's how is the best way to do it
which is just not true it's not true
things evolved that the fundamental
principles of combat leadership don't
change but the tactics that you use can
definitely ma you have to modify your
tactics the enemy's going to modify
their tactics so you have to adjust as
well and so to rely on your personal
experience as how you bolster your
arguments is wrong it's it's a it's an
additive right it's good to say hey look
I've done this before and this is a good
way I remember I had a situation where I
was teaching how to go over the beach
with boats right and I brought up some
things and I said hey look I've done and
I had happened to have done multiple
deployments on a ship and when you're on
a ship you go over the beach a lot and
going over the beach is a complicated
operation
care there's no easy way to do it man
you got gear that's gonna flood out you
got waves you got tide you got surf
you've got sand you've got saltwater
it's a nightmare and that's one of the
things that makes the seals good is that
we have to do this so when you go you
and you insert any other way it's
freakin easy like you step off a
helicopter everything's fine you know
you you uh you get dropped out of a
vehicle everything's fine and you come
over the beach everything is a disaster
there's salt everywhere there's water
everywhere everything's flooded and
broken in your freezing cold it just
sucks and that's that's what our normal
mode of operation is right there so
everything else seems easy but I had a
guy that was saying don't don't ever
bring the boats in and I totally
disagreed with that it was like well it
you have to think about what you're
gonna do is basically what I'm saying
you have to think of what you're gonna
do if you can avoid if the boats come in
and they flip it's a real problem right
it's a real problem if there's surf it's
a real problem and you need to have like
elements ready to just handle the boats
because if something goes wrong so you
can't you you have to really think about
what you're doing in anyways I almost
fell back on like look I've done this
I've done over the beach over and over
again I know the deal it's like well no
actually
cuz the deal is many times when you look
at the surf and you you go you know what
we need to swim in mm-hmm it's gonna
suck but we need to swim in because
risking the boats going through and it's
there's two there's two things that are
pulling at you the waves are big right
you're thinking hey we better get the
boats to bring us in that's actually
counterintuitive because the waves are
big man you flip a boat over and you got
your it's a disaster it's a disaster so
anyways I almost relied on the hey this
is the way we did it and I've done this
a bunch and it's like no that's not Mary
you have to be explained okay here's
what can happen here's the problems and
here's the end his problems for both of
us there's times Rhys one then there's
times we don't but you have to
understand why you're making that
decision you can't just blanket a
decision yeah cuz it gets sketchy
alright anyways this is a big
introduction to SL a Marshall here we go
I gotta say one more thing bro and in
your life and I we've written two books
about our experiences they're not there
of the leadership books but you know we
make it very clear that like hey this is
our memory to the best of our ability
but there's some things that you just
don't you you if you don't know
something it should make a claim but
there's something like you know if you
were participating in d-day you don't
mess up that fact like for me to be like
hey we oh yeah I was on that mission and
so I'm gonna be like oh well actually
you weren't
I mean well when was it and well I did
whatever I was on hundred operations oh
I don't know who's on that one or that
well you know you don't like you it's
understood right people make mistakes
people your memory it fades with memory
I think later night I mean we in both
the intros to extreme ownership in
dichotomy leadership we spelled out you
know this is to the best of our memory
this is an historical document and we
you know at some point I'm sure we'll go
back and and actually get the dates and
explain every single thing that happened
by date and who was there and what
experience took place there like yeah
that would be good to have and
especially now it's probably it's all
unclassified now cuz it's been a long
time but the the kind of errors that
he's making in are like I was at d-day
or I was in the trenches with my brigade
commander on the day that World War one
ended later that's not a small like your
memories not gonna forget that right
yeah it is not gonna happen so tell the
truth and what sucks is this is what
sucks if you don't tell the truth you
discredit everything that you've said
that actually is truthful that's the
problem with this book that's the
problem with this book everything that
it basically you could take this book
and throw it in the garbage can and no
one could really argue with you oh that
guy lied about a bunch of stuff okay
well throw in the garbage can I get it
yeah and if it wasn't for the fact that
hack actually had learned a ton from
this book I would be like well well fell
in the garbage you know but if he
learned from it and then used what he
learned from it to implement in the
Korean War and the Vietnam War it's like
okay you know what I'm gonna pay
attention to it hmm
as a rough thought there's a rough thing
it took me a long time to decide to
cover this book actually yeah in that
crazy make sense though totally makes it
makes sense that it took a long time and
it makes sense that we're here right now
with book in hand both okay I mean more
the long time thing of course yeah you
gotta consider just like that what
there's like a reporter like a like a
news reporter who like said he was in a
helicopter and it got to five you know
that was Hillary Clinton yes she took
sniper fire coming right it's a reporter
that did that too
yeah it was yeah yeah and then he said
like he did took all this stuff and they
was like well I was in two two
helicopters you know uh you know
meanwhile yeah some good stuff yeah he
shouldn't have said that you know just
like are you saying you don't have to
say all that knows there's something
else that happens this catches people
when it comes to storytelling okay I
would explain this if I'm telling you a
story about something taking place and
I'm not a great storyteller I want you
to feel how I felt
hmm so if I say to you like let's say I
got a mortar that exploded fifty yards
from me hmm fifty yards I'm pretty safe
could I get fragged sure I could get
fragged but I'm pretty safe it's still
pretty shocking omits blout biome and
win that first mortar hits you like oh
wait is another more they're gonna hit
me what's going on well when I tell you
hey a mortar hit an 850 meters from me
I'm thinking well that doesn't really
convey how I felt
yeah moment so you know what I'm gonna
do I'm just gonna cut that down the list
I had this mortar hit ten meters from me
and now you're thinking oh dang like
even you I can see it on your face you
get it now
so in order for me to try and convey the
emotions that I actually felt people
start to adjust and you've got to be
careful that they're I don't think
they're doing it intentionally you know
I always put myself in check like okay I
need to tell a good story but I need to
keep the facts strikes yeah right
sketchy yeah that's the thing the facts
so there's a difference between saying
hey this was the big
explosion you'd ever seen in your life
you know like saying that is different
than like this explosion was literally
you know 200 feet in the air well you
could say oh this was a 400 pounds worth
of TNT yeah you can't make those vacu
you make those factors it but hey
something hits 50 meters from you and
you never in mortar before that will
that is a scary thing yeah it's a scary
thing do a metaphor though yes but
here's what's here's what's cool you
know here's what you need here's what I
always need to remember when I tell you
I got a mortar that landed 50 meters
most people are like damn that's scary
enough I don't need to make it more
scary oh yeah let's just keep it real
yeah you even mention the smoke trail
behind the mortar why ain't going up to
me that's scary that's scary yeah I
don't meters so it's not really smoke
it's uh it's like little sparks like a
sparkler Oh like a trail yeah yeah
that's what it sound so here we end up
we end up with SLA Marshalls book lots
to learn from it and yeah so let's get
into it
we'll try and take it for what it's
worth yes sir
and I believe you're gonna find as I was
reviewing this book I'm like yeah
there's so much good information in here
here we got a book in the early years of
world war ii it was the common practice
of public spokesman in the United States
to magnify the role of the machine in
war while minimizing the importance of
large forces of well-trained foot
soldiers hey World War two we're gonna
win this thing with all these big
machines were we're creating once the
total contest between national societies
is predicated it becomes impossible to
write off the ultimate clash between the
masses of men who fight on foot they are
the body of the National Defense there
is no other way out the Society which
looks for an easier way is building its
hope on sand tea I'm already getting
kind of fired up because that's wreath
at SRI l-- yeah
improvisation is the natural order of
warfare the perfect formulas will
continue to be found only on charts
that's good what's the quote that you
clipped out of Dave Burke saying good
deal yeah good deal Dave saying he said
it at the muster it's not a spreadsheet
oh yeah this isn't a spreadsheet
yeah this isn't a spreadsheet anymore
and that's kind of what I thought that
made me think of that because leadership
is not a spreadsheet the hits not a
spreadsheet is not a perfect thing that
you can just put out on a spreadsheet in
okay here's the decision we're gonna
make doesn't work that way mm-hmm all
right here we go
getting back to the book since more than
a century ago when the rifle bullet
began its reign over the battlefield and
soldiers slowly became aware that the
day of close order formations in combat
was forever gone all military thinkers
have pondered the need of a new
discipline it has been generally
realized that fashioning the machine to
man's use in battle was but half of the
problem the other half was conditioning
man to the Machine the mechanisms of the
new warfare do not set their own
efficiency rate in battle they are ever
at the mercy of training methods which
will stimulate the soldier to express
his intelligence and spirit the
philosophy of discipline has adjusted to
changing conditions so think about this
talking about discipline the philosophy
of discipline has adjusted to changing
conditions as more and more impact has
gone into the hitting power of weapons
necessitate necessitating ever-widening
deployments of the forces of battle key
part the quality of the initiative in
the individual has become the most
praised of the military virtues so as we
got these weapons that can shoot and
kill more people at greater distances
people got more spread out the more
spread out people got the more it
becomes important that you have
initiative hmm back to the book it has
been readily seen that the prevailing
tactical conditions increased the
problem of unit coherence in combat
this the only offsets are people are
more spread out the only offset for this
difficulty was to train for a higher
degree of individual courage
comprehension of the situation and self
starting character in the soldier so the
more spread-out people get the more you
have to rely on these individual
soldiers to make the right decisions out
there show initiative that becomes the
new discipline hmm
this is decentralized commanders by the
way from this realization have come new
concepts of discipline which have
altered nearly all the major aspects of
life and of human association within
Western armies we have continued to
grapple with the problem of how to free
the mind of man how to enlarge his
appreciation of his personal worth as a
unit in the battle how to stimulate him
to express his individual power within
limits which are good which are for the
good of all how do we free the mind how
do we and notice this is a little
dichotomy here free the mind to express
individual power but here's the
dichotomy within limits which are for
the good of all so you can't just be
doing what's good for you you can't just
express your be free your mind and do
whatever you think is right for your own
purpose you need to do it for everyone
they're good for all back to the book it
is universally recognized that as the
means of war change so must the
intelligence of man be quickened to keep
pace with the changes our weakness lies
in this that we have never got down to
an exact definition of what we are
seeking failing that we fall short in
our attempt to formulate in training how
best to obtain it and our philosophy of
discipline falters at the vital point of
its practical tactical application I say
that it is a simple thing what we need
in battle is more and better fire what
we need to seek in training are any and
all means by which we can increase the
ratio of effective fire when we have to
go to war the discipline training
methods and the personal policies of our
forces should all be regulated to
conform with this one fundamental need
now
you can see what he's getting out here
this is his big statement this is his
big hypotheses so it's it's actually he
says I say it's a simple thing weaned
what we need in battle is more and
better fire that's his big statement I
don't agree with that like there's other
things there's a lot of other things
going on leadership I think actually the
things that he talked about prior to
this are more important than fire
decentralized command and making people
take initiative and having people step
up and do the right thing for the entire
team but with a free mind making these
things happen and for some reason he
just bypasses all that super important
stuff it says hey no the most poor thing
we need is more and better fire mm-hmm
fire is important hell yes fire is
important that's why I love machine
gunners it's all my machine gunners out
there god bless you mm-hmm you lay down
the fire to all the supporting fire
elements out there artillery close air
love you thank you we need more fire I
agree with that
but that's not that's not the it's not
the thing that we narrow everything down
to which is his hypothesis so a lot of
good information there he narrows it
down to a different direction don't
agree with it and actually I'll go ahead
and say not true it's all these factors
that we need to improve fire is not the
sole thing fires absolutely important
fire wins fire fights absolutely fire
maneuver cover move wins firefights
it helps so fire helps win fire fights
doesn't win it on its own next chapters
called on future war he says the
battlefield is the epitome of war all
else in war when war is perfectly
conducted exist but to serve the forces
of the battlefield and to assure final
success on the field it is on the
battlefield that the issues of war are
decided check concur it should be noted
that all military power is dependent on
civil will it is the nation and not the
army which makes war so I've talked
about that before the will you got to
have the will if you don't have the will
as a nation you're not gonna win
and I've talked about it before the
Wills you gotta have two are the will
stick the will to kill and the will to
die cuz that's what war is
it's killing and dying and if you don't
have those if you don't have the will to
do those two things you should not be
entering war because the outcome is not
gonna be good every improvement in
weapon power is aimed at lessening the
danger on one side by increasing it on
the other consequently every improvement
in weapons is eventually met by a
counter improvement that's jiu-jitsu
right you got that counter come up with
a new move guess what somebody's gonna
come up with a move to counter it that's
always happening with weapons I like
this little line right here decision in
war is a clinching act there's the
action which finally delivers the
victory surely into one's hands decision
decisiveness making the call that's what
you need to do next chapter man on the
battlefield on the battlefield the real
enemy is fear and not the bayonet or
bullet all means of union of power
demand union of knowledge that's a quote
from Robert Jackson and he continues
here it is of the battlefield that I
speak in saying that the mind of the
infantry soldier should be conditioned
to an understanding of its reality
through all stages of his training and
and that's one of the reasons why I
heard so many quotes about SLA marshal
is while we were getting trained people
would refer back to SLA martial and when
I ran training I I knew I had to bring
it up sometimes because I'd say look
here's what's going on hmm
we need to think about this and I'll get
to some of those points later but
training his methodology when he wrote
this book part of the focus is like hey
we need to train people differently and
and what he says about training is 100%
valid a hundred percent valid back to
the book he needs to be taught the
nature of the field as it is in war and
as he may experience it someday for if
he does not acquire a soldier's view of
the field his image of it will be formed
from the reading of novels or the
romance written by war correspondence of
which he was won by the
or from the viewing of or from viewing
the battlefield as it is imagined to be
by Hollywood one of the purposes of
training should be to remove these false
ideas of battle from his mind totally
agree absolutely to give the soldier a
correct concept of battle is a far
different thing from encouraging him to
think about war this is it so think
about what I just said to give the
soldier a correct concept of battle is a
far different thing from encouraging him
to think about war
the latter is too vast the canvass it
includes too much detail which is
confusing to his mind and he material to
his personal problem Hoosick don't think
about this big picture you do you think
about what's happening we have surpassed
all other armies and outstripped common
sense in our effort to teach man
something about war he's counseled about
Wars causes which is a good thing on
which those rare occasions when he is
when the instruction is in qualified
hands he's told about how the soldiers
and sailors of other nations observe
courtesy and foster tradition he is even
bored by lectures on the strategy and
logistics of high command but he does
not get what he requires most the simple
details of common human experience on
the field of battle as a result he goes
to the supremely testing experience of
his lifetime as almost a total stranger
so he learned all these you know what
actually when life took over the junior
officers course coming out of buds
it was very focused on the big picture
stuff and it wasn't helping these guys
being prepared to be in a seal platoon
and Lafe was like no I gotta change this
you can still talk about the stuff and
it's important to you don't throw it out
but you got to teach people what the
human experience on the battlefield is
and that's what lave tried to do and
that's what I tried to do and I took all
the training in and my training was
further along when I took it over you
know we were already move in that
direction or it already reflected that
but a lot of the stuff that Leif was
being taught and Leif's course was not
the human experience on the field of
battle they've tried to get that in
there and he did a good job of it back
to the book the price for failure
so that we talking about to train these
people protect Li the price for failure
is paid all up and down the line men go
into action the first time haltingly and
gropingly as if they were lost at night
in the deep woods lives are wasted
unnecessarily time has lost ground that
might be taken has overlooked it is not
necessary that these misfortunes befall
organizations simply because they are
new to battle it is possible that the
infantry soldier can be trained to
anticipate fully the true conditions of
the battlefield it is possible that
units can be schooled to take full and
prompt action against dis unit against
the dis unifying effect of these
conditions fear is ever-present but the
but is the uncontrolled fear that is the
enemy of successful operation and the
control of fear depends upon the extent
to which all dangers and distractions
may be correctly anticipated and
therefore understood llegada simulate
battle that's what you got to do and
they did a great job when I was going
through my work ups they did a great job
of doing that when I took over and was
running training we brought it even to
the next level it was freaking mayhem
out there and I had many people we're
gonna have some guys that are retiring
in the future that are coming on the
podcast that went through my work ups
they will tell you being an actual cop
that was easier it was easier and that's
what my goal was we want this train
you'd be so chaotic and what do you
think about this right here when you
think about law enforcement training
should be the same way you want these
guys completely tested you want it to be
harder than anybody they ever have to
deal with you want the situation to be
more stressful than they're gonna deal
with in real life and that's how you get
them prepared next the heart of the
matter is to relate to man is to relate
the man to his fellow soldier as he will
find him on the field of combat to
condition him to human nature as he will
learn to depend on it when the ground
offers him no comfort and weapons fail
he talks a lot about human nature I talk
a lot about human nature
mmm-hmm when you were when you'd hear
about this oh this guy did you know that
he was a faker back then it was yes but
it was
you know how there's two sides to every
story yeah it seemed like to me until I
read about face and I was like okay
there's the actual side there's the
actual side it is because you know
hackworth said look this is what he
actually did here's the military records
so but up until I read about face it was
kind of like Oh Leslie there's some
weird stuff about his career but you
know yeah kind of what is a gray area
yeah
but not everyone some people would talk
about him like he was the man without
any demerits against him without any
question against him right which kind of
adds to the little hodgepodge opinions
yeah that is that was a crazy thing I
mean when hackworth was just talking
about opening that I read this is
something that is just when you read it
you know oh God
so he's saying that hackworth is saying
that basically he he didn't want to
bring up the fact he stayed on his good
side right hey he valued his career slam
had a lot of power so he's just gonna
stay on his good side and then he's
saying how many other guys were doing
that how many guys were just staying on
SLA Marshalls good side because they
wanted to continue their career and in
order to do that they're like oh you
know I'm not going to say anything about
it yeah and that actually bolsters his
power cuz Hawk Worth at this time right
if you get a blessing from hackworth
it's like that's real problem member
what remember would Mook Jim mu qiyamah
said about Hackworth he's like everybody
knew Hackworth everybody knew him he was
mr. infantry coolest nickname ever by
the way if I come back in another world
now I'm gonna do whatever it takes to
earn the nickname mr. infantry that's
just as legit as it gets so but when you
got Hackworth going oh yeah VI work with
slam good guy right that's a little oh
that's awkward saying that so it's it's
like and now there's other generals are
saying this cuz everybody just wants to
protect their little career and he's
saying he was opportunistic this is
Hackworth coming out straight-up calling
himself guilty yeah so do you think this
happens all the time though right that's
what you think all the time do you think
that it's kind of in a way your duty
to kind of to call it out okay there's
answer that question if you call it out
yeah and it doesn't work and you get
blacklisted by SLA marshal and now you
don't make rank and now you're not in
charge and they shove you off to some
bill it over and wherever and now you
have no him no more influence did you do
a good job did you make a right call if
you play the game and you just go along
with it and you try and get yourself to
a position of power where you can
actually have more influence and you
would have had and you had to you had to
bite your tongue was that the good move
mm but what if you didn't really get to
where you wanted to be and now you
accelerated him and he turned it again
you know I mean that's that's a very
tough decision to make and that's why
that's why you gotta be it's why you
gotta be tactful you gotta think about
what's going on you got to think about
the long-term consequences of what
you're about to do that's why leadership
is challenging and that's why playing
these little political games which you
have to play in every different
organization people don't think there's
political games the military golf it's a
big political game it's a big giant
political game the same thing in
companies corporations yeah right that's
the way the world works you got to play
the game yeah so like even socially you
know where let's say you know a person
and I've been in this situation before
not even necessarily in it I'm not
saying that and I'm not saying that
either but I'm saying plausible delete
like faker Dyer and you know they they
gotta know and you know just I'm saying
social scenario where you know they have
a nice car but then they oh like ten
people like tens of thousands of dollars
because how they screwed them over in
something like their friends and all
this stuff right yeah meanwhile there's
a small group of people who know all
about that stuff and then we see you
know we'll see or you'll see this person
as this huge faker going around town as
this huge faker
um but everyone else who's not in it
sees them as this great person who's
like you know whatever is it your duty
on a social level seems saying like to
be like hey because you know I guess it
could be said like hey you're kind of
protecting other people from getting
screwed in that same
for sure um but at the same time it's
like yeah do you especially if you don't
have a dog I have to look at what the
what what is this person doing that's
benefiting anyone if all they're doing
is screwing people over I'm gonna say
something for sure yeah if this person
if this individual is somehow you know
running a big charity organization right
right like that's a legit thing right
that could happen he's donate money or
getting people to donate or whatever
maybe I'd try and mitigate it more but
you know in a social situation this
person just sounds like they're gonna
screw people over I think I'm gonna I
think I'm gonna drop dime yeah yeah yeah
on one hand you're kind of like yeah let
me let me and not the kind you're not
gonna go on the radio or something and
broadcast it well you don't have to go
on the radio you can go on the social
media but you're not gonna go on and
announce these things it's just like if
it ever comes up here's you know here's
here's a situation that could unfold if
you call this person out now that note
now they stop whatever form of income
they have now no one that they owes
money to is actually gonna ever get a
payback right it's not gonna be
problematic yeah or you now you have
like a little conflict with this person
now you got to deal with whatever it
comes of that I'm saying it's kind of
like don't like what do you call it you
need you know muddy the waters or
whatever like don't disturb the waters
kind of thing and then hopefully which
usually actually is the case in certain
social situations where they're gonna
play themself anyway so yeah that's you
know that gets out you can't like but I
don't like people taking people's money
yeah so I'm gonna have a problem with
this person yeah that's the bottom line
yeah fully and I think most people
that's how it is you know they don't
like that so and I think the weird thing
is social people they don't they don't
they don't they don't be coming around
me if they I kind of give off the vibe
of like hey you don't want to be acting
that way around me yeah so I don't have
a lot of people like that hanging around
yeah
going back to the book only when human
rather than material aspects of
operation are put uppermost can tactical
bodies be conditioned to make the most
of their potential unity so the human
being he's saying that human beings are
more important it is beyond question
that the most serious and repeated
breakdowns on the field of combat are
caused by failure of controls over human
nature I'm gonna read that again it is
beyond question that the most serious
and repeated breakdowns on the field of
combat are caused by failure of the
controls over human nature not tactics
not weapons not machinery not physical
strength but human nature and guess what
I agree with that I agree with that we
all grant that the soldier must be
trained for initiative and encouraged to
think about what his problem while in
combat so he again he talks about a lot
about initiative and that's one of the
things that that I think was very
positive and that's one of the things
that influenced me knowing that it was
important for people to have initiative
and knowing that you can't control it
everyone on the battlefield an
understanding decentralized command to
the book our training methods are
conditioned by the ideal of automatic
response so he's saying like we think
that the best thing the best ideal is
just automatic response that's what we
want at the same time our observation of
the battlefields reality makes it clear
to us that we need men who can think
through their situation and steel
themselves for action according to the
situation so we don't want automatic
response we want people that can think
the thinking soldier the man who's
trained for self-starting cannot be
matured in a school which holds to the
vestiges of the belief that automatic
action is the ideal thing in the soldier
again this is undeniable undeniable we
want people that are think for
themselves mm-hmm I hold it to be one of
the simplest truths of
or that the thing which enables an
infantry soldier to keep going with his
weapons is the near presence or the
presumed presence of a comrade it
happened too frequently in our army that
a line company was careless about the
manner in which it received a new
replacement the stranger was not
introduced to his superiors nor was
there time for him to feel the friendly
interest of his immediate associates
before he was ordered forward with the
attack the result was the man's total
failure in battle and has returned to
the rear as a mental case so it is far
more than a question of the soldiers
need of physical support from other men
he must have at least some feeling of
spiritual unity with them if he is to do
an efficient job of moving and fighting
this is very important I work with
companies all the time so you take an
army unit and you throw a random guy in
there a random replacement and no one
meets him and no one talks to him and
all of a sudden they're going on an
attack he's gonna fail yeah that's the
statement because he doesn't under he
doesn't know anyone else and he goes
more into detail on this in the in the
book but that happens with companies
where they have someone new new person
check on board they get hired they check
on board no one meets him no one greets
him no one becomes friends with them
they're in their own isolated little
world the pressure starts to come and
they bail when they break he talks more
about this in Chapter four which is
called combat isolation and there's a
quote that it starts off from Major
General Charles W O'Daniel and it says
the finest theories and most minut plans
often crumble complex systems fall by
the wayside parade-ground formations
disappear our splendidly trained leaders
vanish the good men which we had at the
beginning are gone the raw truth is
before us
that's good yeah
and obviously law of combat number to
keep things simple that's exactly what
he's talking about you gotta keep things
simple but he's also saying that
everything that you come up with these
complex things they're gonna fall apart
in combat that's what happens mm-hmm and
now he's talking about that the name of
the chapter is combat isolation and he
starts talking about what it's like when
these soldiers get on the battlefield
he's talking about the battlefields cold
and and it's harsh and it's empty and
there's it's it chills a man's soul is
what he's saying and then when the fire
starts here we go back to the book he
finds himself suddenly almost alone in
his hour of greatest danger and he can
feel the danger but there is nothing out
there nothing to contend against it is
from the mixture of mystification and
fear that there comes the feeling of
helplessness which in turn produces
greater fear that is what green troops
are up against time and again I have
heard them say after their first try at
combat by God there was never a
situation like it we saw no one we were
fighting phantoms and as frequently they
have and as frequently they have added
this though their convictions about the
matter were holy at odds with the facts
of the situation we had to do it all
alone
we got no support on either flank so
he's talking about the fact that when
you feel alone on the battlefield and
the fact that guys would come back and
say even though they were fully
supported it didn't matter they thought
they were alone out there and that
that's what he's talking about he goes
on the enemy now he's talking about a
firefight situation the enemy fire
builds up its aim becomes true or the
man spread the men spread further and
further from each other moving
individually to whatever cover is
nearest or affords the best protection a
few of them fire their pieces at first
they do so almost timidly as if fearing
a rebuke for wasting ammunition when
they do not see the enemy others do
nothing some fail to act mainly because
they are puzzled what to do and their
leaders do not tell them
others are wholly unnerved and can
neither think nor move in sensible
relation to the situation such response
as the men make of to enemy fire tends
mainly to produce greater separation in
the elements of the company thereby
intensifying the intensifying the
feeling of isolation and the insecurity
of its individuals the junior leaders
are affected as much as the rifle files
so when chaos starts people start to be
alone then again this can apply to the
battlefield this can apply the business
world when chaos starts people start to
focus on their own little world
and the more you focus on your own
little world the more separation there
is the less unity there is in the in
your unit to make something happen now
he goes on back to the book could one
clear commanding voice be raised even
though it be the voice of an individual
without titular Authority they would
obey or at least the stronger characters
would do would do so and the weaker
would begin to take heart because
something is being done I got to see
this over when I was running training
got seized over and over and over and
over again and as a matter of fact we
lay for a chapter about it in the
dichotomy of leadership of situations
where one situation in particular where
there's no voice no one's taking charge
finally someone steps up to take charge
and it's like boom everything changes
but clear commanding voices are all too
rare on the battle on the field of
battle so they wait doing nothing and
inaction takes further toll on their
resolve more Grievous losses will no
doubt come to this band of men in time
but as a company this is the worst hour
that they will ever know so it's a
downward spiral if no one steps up and
starts making calls you start taking
casualties now if people panic even more
they get more in their own little world
they become more detached from each
other less unity of what you're trying
to make happen
back to the book it would serve no
purpose to dwell on the discouraging
detail of this ordeal if it were not for
the belief that much of it is
unnecessary and that the infantry
soldier can find a bed
away one must not come to rest on Klaus
Fitz gloomy warning that quote in war
the novice is met only by pitch black
night on beyond that there are words to
be read it is of the first importance
that the soldier higher low should not
have to encounter in war things which
seen for the first time set him in
terror or perplexity
so that's Klaus Fitz talking about
training you've got to get people ready
for this chaos and mayhem you've got to
get it get them ready for it you've got
to get them ready you got to show them
that when people panic and people are
getting separated
that one commanding voice one leader
stepping up and leading will have a
massive impact on the situation and
failure to do that will also have a
massive impact but it'll be a massive
negative impact now he talks chapter
five is called ratio of fire and here we
get into his little hypotheses I'm not
gonna waste a lot of time on it but I'm
gonna bring it up back to the book now I
do not think I've seen it stated in the
military manuals of this age or in any
of the writings meant for the
instruction of those who lead troops
that a commander of infantry will be
well advised to believe that when he
engages the enemy not more than
one-quarter of his men will ever strike
a real blow unless they're unless they
are compelled by almost overpowering
circumstances or unless all junior
leaders constantly ride herd on troops
with specific mission of increasing
their fire the 25% estimate stands for
even for well-trained and campaigned
seasoned troops I mean that 75% will not
fire or will not persist in firing
against the enemy and his works these
men may face danger but will not fight
so that's his hypothesis and actually
the beginning of this book has a
foreword in it that I'm just gonna touch
on the four words written by a guy named
Russell Glenn and he he points out some
of the disputes against this
about this this low ratio fire so here
we go back to the book this is the
introduction so this isn't SLA marshal
this is from the introduction from
Russell Glenn marshals ratio of fire
values did not go unchallenged even when
they first appeared in 1947 General
James M Gavin World War two commander of
the 82nd Airborne Division discounted
the low estimates as did Harry wo canard
who served in 101st Airborne Division in
every one of its combat actions during
world war ii and later commanded the 1st
Cavalry Division in Vietnam the
legendary general Bruce Clark commander
of the US forces that defended st. vith
during the Battle of the Bulge
flatly discounted Marshall finding his
values ridiculous and dangerous
assertions absolute nonsense another
combat veteran British author George
MacDonald Frazer instead questioned
Marshalls explanations for why soldiers
failed to engage the enemy Fraser had so
one of the things that Marshall says is
that people are aren't taught not to
kill and you know it's against the
commandments of God and it's bad to kill
and so that's one of the things we have
a moral and inherent moral objection to
killing and so so this guy Donald Fraser
Frazer had served in Burma as an
infantryman though he recognized that
moral upbringing might influence men's
behavior his first-hand experience
failed to support Marshalls rationale
Fraser wrote that we all have kindly
impulses fostered by 2,000 years of
Christian teaching gentle Jesus and love
thy neighbor but we have the killer
instinct to the murderous impulse of the
hunter and so the introduction of the
book goes on and took talks about many
vets that just outright deny this and I
do too
and I never saw I never saw or felt any
hesitation or saw anyone that I was
hesitate in any way to engage in fact
quite the opposite
most guys were more than ready to get
after it and I'm not just talking about
seals I'm talking about Army infantryman
I'm talking about Marines the guys are
guys are not hesitating I mean broadly
you could never make a statement like
this could you make a statement that
some people hesitate yes you could make
that statement but to broadly say that
only 15 to 25 percent of people are
gonna actively engage the enemy from
everything I saw that's patently untrue
now the advantage in what we had for an
advantage and Marshall kind of claims
this too is that once World War two is
over and they started training us to
shoot at one of the big objections he
has that that guys were getting trained
to shoot
bullseye targets right so you're
training shooter pulls like when you
first see a man you're like oh no that's
a man mm-hmm
we my whole career I barely ever shot a
bull's eye target we did that when we
had to qualify with a rifle or a pistol
every single other time we shot we were
shooting a man-shaped target I mean we
would shoot little round targets or what
were they called head plates right of
course you didn't get heads
we're shooting body shots were shoot
that's what we do all the time and we'd
shoot so we shoot targets with pictures
on them with faces on them that look
like people and then on top of that we
did force on force training where we're
actually shooting paintballs or
simunition at other human beings and
we're gunning them down so there's a lot
of conditioning that we had that maybe
that's why we were so much more apt and
able and willing to shoot but yeah it's
from you know you can see from what
these other vets said and these other
leaders said and my personal experience
and you'll find that I think sl8
Marshall like I said I think he just had
a hypothesis he wanted to talk about and
threw it out there without really good
facts behind
so I'm not gonna waste a bunch of time
talking about that and I'm going to go
into the next chapter fire is the cure
finally it is the volume of fire that
counts you win if you kill more of the
enemy than he can kill of you if you
cannot your defeat in that Secretary of
War Robert P Patterson and again I'll go
back to this fire counts for sure it's
important but you got a maneuver it's
cover and move it's not just covering
fire it's like you got a cover and move
that's that's to me they go hand in hand
which actually he says back to the book
fundamentally fire must always be beaten
by fire fundamentally movement is the
means of increasing the efficiency of
one's own fire until the last strength
of the enemy's fire is reduced to a
vanishing point okay I mean okay if you
want to say that you're maneuvering so
that you can maneuver so you can fire
even better that's that's technically
true or you're maneuvering so you can
break contact but you could say that
here's another quote let us not think of
mobility in an army general Charles P
Summerall once said unless we think of
mobility accompanied by violence that's
cover move that's fire maneuver that's
what we're talking about combat can
cannot ever approximate the conditions
of field maneuvers fears of varying sort
afflict the soldier in battle the unit
commander soon comes to realize that one
of his difficulties is to get men to
leave cover because of enemy bullets and
the fear they instill in training there
being no real bullet danger even on the
courses which employed live ammunition
every advance under a supposed enemy
fire is unrealistic - in training the
soldier does not have a man as his
target he is not shooting with the idea
of killing there is a third vast
difference in the two conditions the
rifleman and training is usually under
close supervision and the chief pressure
upon him is to give satisfaction to his
pieria whereas the rifleman engaging the
enemy is of necessity pretty much on his
own and the chief pressure on him is to
remain alive if possible when the
infantrymen mind when the infantryman's
mind is gripped by fear his body is
captured by inertia which is fears
Siamese twin in an attack half of the
men on a firing line are in terror and
the other half are unnerved so wrote
major-general JFC fuller when he was a
young captain so again this is what I
kind of already talked about the idea
that in training you're shooting it
you're not shooting with this intent to
kill and wheat that's what we did all
the time I mean that's just how we're
old in fact they make targets we're like
blood comes out when you shoot and
balloon blows up and blick you see blood
so they're trying to condition you and
they talk about this with video games to
write that these young kids come up just
killing all the time in these video
games which are very very realistic and
therefore they get conditioned to
killing and they don't think it's a big
deal anymore
which clearly that you could tie that
into school shootings a lot of people
tie that into school shootings and say
hey these kids were playing these video
games or there's killing people all the
time and that conditioned them to be
able to kill these innocent people in a
school so there is like I said for me
the all I ever shot at basically was
human targets things that look like
people and again I've seen the video
games that they are so realistic it's
unbelievable and so that's another good
form of conditioning to get you over the
if you have any moral objection to
killing now the the counter statement
that is is it good for people to get
over the moral condition of killing
mm-hmm some people know if you're not a
soldier that's probably a bad thing I
would say yeah yeah even the videogame
thing it seems like there's like a step
before that to force someone to get
conditioned to kill him because I don't
know obviously might last in tense video
game experiences like PlayStation 2
which seems like a long time ago but so
yeah video games are realistic but it
see
like that they have to get past a
certain step to consider the video games
as being training so you guys like when
you guys were you know in training and
you know in the SEAL team do you guys
are specifically training for that
specific thing that was on your mind so
you're past the point of the moral
objection part of it yeah I'm saying so
let's say you weren't past the moral
objection part of it and you were just
shooting one of the video games or
shooting at the range or shooting at
these other things and you're like hey I
know this is I'm not training for
anything specifically I'm just sort of
doing it whether it be for fun or to get
better at shooting or or better at this
game or whatever if you're not past the
moral objection part is it really
training you to be less more morally
well I'd say if you're a kid that's like
got some major issues you're thinking
about school shooting and then you're
sitting there playing these video games
and you're killing people over and over
again
it's conditioning yeah yeah that's
doesn't mean you put anyone in a you
know you could get someone that works in
a slaughterhouse they don't think twice
about killing a pig or killing a cow or
whatever that's what they do they don't
think a millisecond about it whereas you
take someone that's never seen an animal
killed before and it'll be disturbing to
them so that right there is their
conditioning is a thing right if you
watch a bunch of you know a bunch of
videos of something being killed you'd
become conditioned to it and if you play
a game where you kill people all the
time you will become conditioned to it
and I only think this is even debatable
yeah but I feel yeah I agree
but I feel like there's this one kind of
crucial step before that like if you
consider a slaughterhouse person mm-hmm
like there's a difference between
working in a slaughterhouse and being
conditioned to the sight and the smell
and the experience of doing it but not
having the barrier that's like okay I'm
gonna make a decision to do this under
you know a different circumstance
something that's more more morally tied
well yeah I mean let's face the fact
there's millions and others hundreds of
millions of people that play video games
all day long and they're not going out
there and I have no intention of going
out there but you okay so yeah I see
what you're saying if if you start
thinking that way and that becomes your
intent than it is conditioning because
you can even consider someone on the
where let's say they're morally well the
moral barrier has been crossed in their
head or their weird they're Psychopaths
I don't know you know in their brain and
then they've never killed anyone or
anything like that so I heard is
actually read this thing on Saddam
Hussein's son sons yeah yeah and so the
first time how they'd quote-unquote
conditioned them they'd be like hey you
know here's some prisoners shoot him
you know right so the first time now the
first time not can these kids not
conditioned in this way to you know to
have the experience of killing somebody
and watch them dying or whatever so the
first time they gave him a gun
we got the kid shoot someone empties the
clip right
the kid was passed them that moral
barrier a long time ago but first time
unconditioned as far as the experience
goes he turns to the guard and goes hey
can I have another magazine to do it so
he really liked it
he didn't need necessarily conditioning
because he was past that moral part so
I'm saying yeah so yeah it feels like
there they are two separate things but
once you kind of cross that that initial
moral barrier
oh yeah the more conditioned you are the
you know the more effect I mean I hate
to use the word effective but yeah we're
into it you are or the less impact it'll
have like on your brain or whatever yeah
and again we would get quit this is one
of the things we get quoted on SLA
Marshall was this stuff about how as the
targets got more realistic if encouraged
people and made them more comfortable
with shooting and going yeah that's the
point
then I believe yeah that's true it's
true this is the way it is going back to
the book as another experiment unwilling
rifleman may have may be switched to
heavier and more decisive one-man
weapons this sounds like a paradox to
expect greater response to come from
increased responsibility this is good
this is good so he's saying you got a
rifleman this doesn't want to shoot give
him a bigger more effective weapon hmm
he says this sounds like a paradox to
expect greater response to come from an
increased responsibility but it works
I've seen many cases where men
who had funked it badly with a rifle
responded heroically when given a
flamethrower or a bar self-pride and the
ego are the touchstone of most these
remarkable conversions a man may fail
with the rifle because he feels
anonymous and believes that nothing
important is being asked of him so
that's pretty cool cuz I talk about this
all the time like because everyone has a
rifle
everybody had a rifle and he's like ok
let's not really but I'm not really that
important yeah and you give him like a
heavy weapon or a heavy machine gun or a
flamethrower and all of a sudden he's
like oh yeah I'm the man I'm gonna step
up and make this happen which I've
talked about as many times on the
podcast you get someone that's not doing
their job or they need to do a better
job or what have you if you can give
them more responsibility they have a
good chance of actually stepping up and
making things happen Rudolph the
red-nosed reindeer I'm not familiar with
their what yeah ok so Rudolph was the
only one with the red nose and before
they were like they used to tease them
and all this stuff you know so he
thought he was inferior
but when Santa was like hey your nose is
so bright won't you guide my sleigh
toward tonight I get to guide the sleigh
hell yes steps up does the job
check yes they you can edit that out if
you want no no ray it's the same thing
conceptually conceptually
all right next back to the book and last
if we are to strengthen sound training
principles and establish mental
attitudes which are essential to the
understanding of the decisive importance
of fire in tactics we will be well
advised to cease talking about fire and
movement as if the latter were separate
and apart from the former in tactical
fact there and there did not exist an
automatic and unbreakable connection
between them so now he's saying the same
thing that I was saying earlier his fire
is not more important they're the same
thing fire maneuver cover move have to
happen together that's what he's saying
fire is the key to mobility to fire is
to move so he goes on now this next
section again this is great because
next section is called multiples of
information the multiples of information
and what's great about this is he's no
longer talking about he's no longer
talking about tactics of fire maneuver
and this percentage of fire and all that
because he's out of his element there to
me go ahead honest with you this one
he's going to get into his element which
is well I'll go to it I consider to be
of utmost importance that keeping
informed of our men as to current
situation so that each man may perform
his duty with understanding of its
importance in that sergeant David T bolt
in a letter written from the African
theater so you got to keep your people
informed having started to call this
chapter communications I decided against
it for fear that use of that rather
formidable word might interfere with my
communicating to the reader what I
regard as a vital but frequently
overlooked principle of minor tactics if
a word comes to mean too many things it
frequently misses fire at the critical
point that has been the fate of the word
communications it has become another
military catch-all and because it means
so many things it is quite frequently
means nothing to illustrate a regimental
commander asks a company commander
how are your communications and the
ladder replies excellent because his
telephone line is working and his supply
is coming forward and at the same time
he is at the point of despair because he
hasn't had anything worthwhile any
worthwhile intelligence from his flanks
for hours so there's a difference
between communication like I can talk to
you and actual communication you're
telling you what I need to know one
would think that it would become almost
second nature to the commander to reach
eagerly toward supporting forces one
would imagine that whenever on the field
of battle he made contact with a
friendly element that fact would flash a
red light in his brain causing him
automatically to raise the question have
I established full communications do I
know the strength and intentions of the
force now helping me do they know my
strengths and intentions but indeed such
is not the case communications
information is the soul of morale and
combat and the balancing force in
successful tactics and now he talks a
little bit about communication he gives
some guidelines about him and and what
the problems are so information is super
important here some of the problems one
there is a lacking there is lacking a
general recognition of the supreme
importance of the lateral flow of
information to command at the lower
levels is too often neglectful of the
principle that it is not a channel of
information only but a distribution
point so you kind of pass the word three
commanders at the lower levels tend to
be arbitrary judges of what information
deriving from a source lower would be
highly useful to the other elements
lower down instead of abiding by the
rule when in doubt pass it along so when
in doubt pass long now I do have to
throw out that there can be a dicot
there's a dichotomy there because you
can communicate things too much you can
send too many emails you can send too
many message you can do that that can be
a problem and he actually talks about
that dichotomy a little bit so he's just
talking about how much you should
communicate and then he gets to this
point back to the book in the Pacific
fighting I found company commanders
joining a platoon in the line just to
isolate themselves from their telephones
they were literally tired to death of
having the battalion commander insist on
having a fresh progress report every 15
or 20 minutes and the battalion
commander poor-devil was only passing on
the pressure which he had in turn
received from a regimental commander who
is trying to placate division yet one
would observe that unless a battalion
commander is wholly lacking in judgment
or intestinal fortitude he should be
strong enough to take this on his aching
back and not pass it down to the
headquarters which is at grips with the
enemy
this happens all the time in the
military for sure the the senior
commanders called I want to know
going on and tells that to the next
junior guys it's alright I'll find out
what's going on then that guys is all
fine now what's going on and the people
in the front line they can't even fight
because they're too busy trying to
answer the damn questions from up the
chain of command so don't let that
happen
back to the book in the burden island
fight during the invasion of the
Marshalls one of these prodding demands
for more progress raced from division
right through lower headquarters to a
platoon which had been stopped cold by
fire coming from spider holes
arranged in great depth along the beach
the lieutenant got the message and
crawling forward to them his most
advanced rifleman told him to get up and
go on the boy screamed so the whole
goddamn army wants me to wants to kill
me does it okay lieutenant here I go
but watch what happens he was shot dead
almost before he had gotten out of his
tracks
that incident seared deep into the brain
of every man who witnessed it it was
final judgment on the futility of that
kind of leading decentralized commander
call somebody back in the rear or this
lieutenant that's there on the beach
back to the book the all-too-frequent
consequences of such pressure are lying
exaggeration and distortion of the
situation at lower levels resulting in a
false concept of the situation at the
higher the average company commander can
stand only a limited amount of this heat
and then he will knock over a couple of
outhouses and report that he has
captured a village in also this effect
also makes a wishful thinkers of the
most objective sholde soldier he reasons
to himself I'll have that position in
another hour so I'll tell him that I
have it now and get them off my back
so lots about communication being
important next is the riddle of command
many headquarters people become
strangers to the front and cannot speak
its language or understand its
tribulations okay you don't know what's
going on the front lines if you don't
have any idea if you can't even speak
their language anymore you need to get
down there you need to find out what's
going on on the front lines businesses
that means you to the diabolical effect
of even such a relatively simple
instrument as the field telephone is
that it may come to command the
commander the phone actually gets
control of you it changed him to a
system of remote control at first he
sees it only as a successful as a useful
channel for quick communication in
combat then he fears to leave it lest it
should require his presence and
headquarters the moment after he leaves
to go forward this state of mind in turn
creates its own illusion fostering that
fostering the conclusion that under the
new system of war all matters can be
settled at a distance all problems
arising within the zone of fire can be
fully understood without ever going
there and all moral values which once
attended the commander's effort to
impress his men with his personality and
character are somehow sundered by the
new technology of operations out of
sedentary generalship arises evil of
troops which while obeying mechanically
have no organic thinking responds to the
commander's will so I mean how poignant
is this for it's what we live in today
right everyone thinks they can just send
a text message and the problem solved to
make a quick phone call the problem
solved and actually the reality is
sometimes you need to get down there you
know also the the whole thing about it
controlling you you know I mean do you
ever forget your phone do you have that
at all like when you leave your phone at
home or in the car or something like
that where you don't have it for like oh
yeah you know I don't forget things a
lot yeah so I don't that doesn't really
happen to me a lot but yeah I would say
if I left my phone somewhere I would be
like oh dang I was trying to call me
right now I wonder if
is an emergency going on yeah what's
with but you know back in the day when
we're you know whatever teenagers or
whatever Oh
pre cellphones teenage pre cellphone I
was right yeah there was no there was no
there was no internet I was telling my
kids the other day that when I was a kid
there was no internet it was not a thing
yeah that's like saying there's no roads
yes the same thing yeah for my kids
they're like what they were look at me
like what what did you believe cuz
Johnny you had the good of a library go
to look something up get an encyclopedia
I've never thinking encyclopedias were
more or like holy yeah and I mean there
were so many areas I think that was like
up like a holy buff nickel filled with
my mom Anna had a had an OE d Oxford
English Dictionary not the foot the for
one is volumes the phone is 26 volumes
or something crazy like yeah but my mom
had one that was big I mean it was big
it was six inches thick hmm yeah it was
like six maybe six inches thick and big
and it had little tabs little
invitations finger yeah you think but
I'm to me that thing seemed like some
kind of Bible yeah some kind of just
seems so filled with knowledge you and
if you didn't know what a word was you
just had to go look it up and that thing
you didn't know what a thing was you
look it up in the encyclopedia library
and look it up in the encyclopedias
nowadays you're three seconds away
you got that Google yeah you want to
look in the dictionary calm the calm
don't need those fingers unless you got
that read the app OAD a boom even better
cuz you got to get that etymology of the
word too you won't know where it comes
all that stuff yeah then you got um what
what's the street language won't what is
Helen one urban dictionary yeah downsell
era but here's the thing it's weird it's
like it is fun and it's funny but it's
very useful because you know well
they'll say stuff and you be like wait
I've had you look some things up on
urban dictionary
I'm trying to think of a good example
right now but I can't think of one next
time I will I will
I will note yeah that is you know I got
teenage kids yes so sometimes they got
some words yeah you gotta know that they
were saying something a couple years ago
hi fee remember no I don't remember that
oh that's not all that's new how what
does it mean well I don't know if I can
define it specifically but it means like
get fired up like it's like dope oh okay
50 cent or somebody I don't know anyway
but yeah but yeah but that's the thing
though you you lose or you forget your
cell phone you go to the store I don't
know
you're gonna bonds and you leave by
accident and whatever your phone at home
it's like oh yeah and just like how you
said you got those thoughts that call
what if there's an emergency what if
someone's calling me kind of thing that
calls presence or this is the one day
that there's like any Meridian not to
say that you can't have an emergency I
totally can but it's like of literally
the 99.99999 percent of the time you
have access to that phone that one teeny
teeny tiny sliver of time that you don't
owe now all the emergencies gonna come
soon saying and you think back to when
you when there was no cellphones it's
like how did you ever get along no I'm
doing that right now
I'm going with my without my cell phone
but everyone around here's the thing
though with that everyone around you
kind of feels the same thing so like for
example if you go to the store all right
if I go to the store people know I go to
the store or people know I went to store
my wife knows you know maybe if I'm like
hanging out with friends ready I'm gonna
store real quick right mmm we're having
a barbecue I don't know they expect me
to have my phone and I expect to have a
phone so it's like that communication
now communication the standard of
communication is way higher now yeah
Susan like your voice to someone else's
I'll tell you one thing that is a kind
of a bummer and I you know for a long
time I responded to like everybody that
reached out to me mmm-hmm and and I just
can't I mean I can't do it I just it's
physical I would be doing nothing but
sitting around doing that yeah yeah and
it's really cool man I get letters and
emails and
Facebook and DMS on you know and I just
don't have time and I feel bad you know
I read most everything yeah but it's
been getting crazy and here's the thing
in I think this is important to
understand overall for kind of for you
for sure me for everyone when someone
you know how like someone will text you
or someone will send you a like a
message yeah long message and some it's
easy to think like hey you could have
responded with like just something you
know rather than nothing but here's the
thing
it that's not true because if someone
sends you a text message or specially
something long and meaningful like you
don't want to just reply back yeah okay
yeah or okay I'll text you later more
about this message that that makes me
less sense you want to have something
kind of thought out yeah so it's not
just a small little response or you know
who doesn't have time to send one text
way the thing is yeah physically sending
the text doesn't take any time but to
consider your valid or appropriate
response to most texts and mesh in your
case where you get messages legit
messages you can't just be like cool
yeah and then move on to the next I
can't do that no I know so you got it
like consider all these things and then
all that consideration that's what takes
the time yeah and mental energy by the
way like like for like you can't go in
one direction mentally and just pivot
real quick and be like yeah let me just
mentally accommodate this you know it's
like man it takes more thought than that
so it's hard to fit it all in thank you
for you know it is man I feel bad when I
can't get back to people but I
appreciate them reach now and letting me
know that they're getting good
information right whether it's
work-related whether it's the individual
person related their kids whatever war
your kid I mean all kinds of good stuff
and I'm so stoked but like you said it's
a like I can't literally just cannot see
its ride yeah yeah I try so I posted
today I was like hey it's Monday
sometimes life gets out by hand you got
to go you got to attack yeah
and that's why I was feeling this
weekend I was like because I've been on
the road we went to Maine didn't get a
lot of work done in Maine because we
were working in Maine we were rolling
and then we were working and recording
podcasts and interviewing and all this
other stuff so didn't have a lot of time
out there got a little bit behind life
got the upper hand on me and so I was
kind of feeling it on when I got home
and then what I said was oh you know
what I'm gonna do
so Sunday I just I'm just gonna work all
day just get you just get busy get the
up yeah yeah cuz people were talking
about the kids podcast yeah the podcast
yeah where's the other guy oh hey okay
my kids love listening to it we're
listening to it for the we're listening
to the first 16 episodes for the ninth
time now can you make another one or are
you giving up on that like so so I got
after that recorded some of that today
but but that's what I did go on the
attack like and that really does really
like by the end by by the end of Sunday
I was like oh my god and I thought I
thought it's gonna be a late night on
Sunday I thought midnight which you know
I don't want to go to bed a midnight on
a Sunday night I got to got done it's
like 9:45 at night and I was ahead I was
back ahead and I had to get aggressive I
had to dig deep and I had to go like
okay this is what's going on so if you
start feeling that little life's getting
the upper hand if you if you let it
continue to maneuver on you it's gonna
get worse if you go oh oh you think
you're gonna get the upper enemy watch
this I'm gonna get aggressive I'm gonna
knock out so much stuff in the next 24
hours
you're not even know what just happened
son yeah so that's how I went out yeah
as is actually I made the video on
Monday technically it was a Sunday
evolution but by the time Monday rolled
around I was back at the game like if
you get the there is some someone else
something else get to the upper hand
it's like dang you got to work double
time just so it doesn't have the upper
hand anymore once you get the upper hand
okay yeah you can boom you can you find
your way the by the way when when you
get the upper hand it's like when you're
playing a sport and the team starts to
get the little upper hand and then they
just they can start taking a little bit
more risks they get a little bit more
calm
I'm Lynn yeah and they get the moment'
yeah they get the momentum and they
start going and that's productive right
that they a wide net score run up the
score boy yeah
and so that's same thing I'm thinking
but I had me on the ropes a little bit
you know it was on the ropes us on the
ropes over here and I had to ride to
getting I woke up early
I know it's just boom I'm gonna start
hammering and that's what you gotta do
finished reading a book wrote another
book edited a book I had a stack of
stuff come get some
be aggressive okay so the communication
think so here's the other thing that
happens with modern communications text
messaging emails you started losing that
little personal touch which is important
here we go back to the book with his
characteristically warm humor General
Eisenhower has commented on the value of
the personal factor in the commander's
relation to his men under the conditions
of modern war I found that it did a
great deal of good to get down to my
troops in the combat area my presence
relaxed them and made them feel more
comfortable about the situation but I
was not deceived as to the reason I knew
what was running through their minds
they were saying to themselves there
must be less danger than we thought or
the old man wouldn't be here yeah get
down talk the troops here we talk about
this is a part of the nature of the
combat soldier once he loses that faith
it becomes very difficult to resolve it
he will lose it very quickly when he
sees that casualties are wasted on
useless operations or when he begins to
feel that he is in any respect the
victim of bad planning or faulty
concepts that's important mm-hm then he
responds to that principle which was
once well stated by General James
hardboard discipline and moral influence
the inarticulate vote that is constantly
taken by masses of men when the order to
comes to move forward when the order
comes to move forward
a variant of the crowd psychology that
inclines it to follow a leader but the
army does not move forward until the
motion is carried
unanimous consent only follows
cooperation between the invent
individual men in ranks that's a bold
statement like hey you can give that
order but until everybody kind of knows
that it's a good plan we're not going
here's another good statement by rough
approximation 60% of the art of command
is the ability to anticipate 40% of the
art of command is the ability to
improvise to reject the preconceived
idea that has been tested and proved
wrong in the crucible of operations and
to rule by action instead of acting by
rules that's a good one by the way
that's the entire order command right
that's that's 100 percent anticipation
and ability to improvise obviously
there's some more factors available
those are some important ones there's
and I don't think I pulled it out but
there's also one part in the book where
it says anticipation is important but
it's but it's you can't just say someone
hey anticipate Harger yeah they
anticipate more it's hard to say that
that's someone someone's got to have
experience someone's gonna have the
mindset for it they gotta ly gonna free
their mind and open their mind so that
they can be aware of little nuances that
are happening in changes that are
occurring you can't be down in the weeds
or else you can't anticipate anything
because you're getting knocked around
and the dust and the dirt yeah so it's
kind of like a pay attention kind of
thing like it's a it's a way of paying
attention I think really the key is
detachment yeah because if you can't
detach you're not gonna be able to
anticipate anything cuz you're in and
that's why there's a obvious dichotomy
here yeah do you want to go down and be
with the troops absolutely but can you
go down and be with troops so much that
you lose track of what's happening at a
strategic level and you can anticipate
what's happening no you can't do that
dichotomy a leadership you got to
balance it back to the book during war
it oftentimes happens that one company
by trial and error finds the true
solution for some acute problem which
can
cern's everyone but when that happens to
a company I can assure you that is the
exceptional company officer who takes
the initiative and passes it passes his
unique solution along to his superior -
even after he has proved in battle that
the idea works a good company idea in
tactics is likely to remain confined to
one company indefinitely even though it
would be a benefit to the whole military
establishment and this is what this is
dealing with silos it happens in the
military it happens in the civilian
sector somebody figures something out
and they keep it to themselves the
fundamental purpose of all training
today should be to develop the natural
faculties and to stimulate the brain of
the soldier rather than to treat him as
a cog which has been fitted into a great
machine got to keep pointing that out
loyalty in the masses of men waxes
strong in the degree that they are made
to believe that real importance is
attached to their work and to their
ability to think about their work so you
got to get people engaged and people got
to understand and believe that what
they're doing is important and they
gotta have some kind of say they gotta
have some control over their own fate it
weakens at every point where they
consider that there is a negative
respect for their intelligence this rule
applies whether a man is engaged in
digging a ditch or in working up a
loading table for an invasion so if you
have negative respect for people's
intelligence they're not gonna do a good
job big chunk a little bit of a big
chunk here two square training with a
reality of war it becomes a necessary
part of the young officers mental
equipment for training to instill in him
the full realization that in combat many
things can and will go wrong without it
being anyone's fault in particular so
what did I just say things are gonna
happen is no one's fault does that
really does that really marry up with
the idea of extreme ownership well not
really great because I'm taking
ownership of anything how
keep listening war is aimed at
destruction the fire and general purpose
of the enemy are directed against one's
own personnel material and
communications with the object of
keeping one's own design from coming
into play small plans miscarry because
the wrong man happens to be hit at the
critical moment or the guns which were
counted on are knocked out of action the
problem of command in battle is ever to
establish a safe margin which will allow
for such misadventure there you go so
things are gonna go wrong but what you
have to take ownership of is is figuring
out how you're gonna have a plan that's
gonna overcome those problems back to
the book but this much is certain
there is no system of safeguards known
to man which can fully eliminate the
consequences of accident and mischance
in battle hence the only final
protection is the resiliency and courage
of the commander and his subordinates so
what does that mean when something goes
wrong when something bad happens you
adapt you adjust you you alter your
plans and you continue forward you own
it it therefore follows that the far
object of a training system is to
prepare the combat officer mentally so
that he can cope with the unusual and
the unexpected as if it were the
altogether normal and give him poise in
a situation where all else is in dis
equilibrium then over and over again and
how do you do that how do you do that in
the civilian sector right prepare your
people you roleplay with people you give
them hard problems
you make them figure things out you put
them in tough situations so that they
become accustomed to it but how to do it
I would say that the beginning lies in a
system of schooling which puts the
emphasis on teaching soldiers how to
think rather than what to think even
though such a revolutionary idea would
put the army somewhat ahead of our
civilian education that's a common thing
that gets said in military training is
teaching people how to
not what to think and this is a good the
test of fitness of command is the
ability to think clearly in the face of
unexpected contingency or opportunity
improvisation is the essence of
initiative in all combat just as
initiative is the outward showing of the
power of decision you think about this
when you're raising your kids - that's a
good little something to think about
you want your kids to be able to think
mmm
think yeah that's where you gotta have
them doing some creative stuff yeah
right sure jiu-jitsu creative but you
gotta gotta throw some other stuff out
back to the book the darkest hour for
the novice and war comes with the recoil
after the unit has been badly hit it is
then that the young commander has
greatest need of the friendship and
steadiness of his superior or of any
other officer whose judgment he respects
criticism or tactical counsel are of no
value at this time they can be given
that later if necessary but in the wrong
hour they add to the hurt let him get
out his crying towel when he is told how
it happened the important thing is that
he be given a pat on the back and
insurance and assurance that he did his
full duty and some little reminder that
while he may feel that his losses are
excessive such incidents are unavoidable
feature of combat and do not keep one
from coming back in the next round in
secret in siegfried sassoon memories of
an infantryman the young lieutenant
tells of emerging from a bloody trench
raid and meeting his colonel this was
Kent Colonel Ken Jack I'd never met
before and it was the first time I had
ever shared any human equality with him
he spoke kindly to me in his rough way
and in doing so he made me very thankful
that I had done what I could so I mean
this is a very important especially for
folks that are in the military or in
services where you can take losses and
that is when you're in charge it's
the time he is not then to provide
tactical counsel right that's not the
time first you've got to let the person
get over the emotional hump help them
through that and if you got to go back
and debris from later that's what you do
I think I think everybody needs to pay
attention to that and I mean you could
say the same thing for businesses you
know if somebody makes a big mistake and
they feel bad about it and it hurts them
or they get people fired and they cost a
bunch of money or something like you
might not want to jump on their back
immediately a man remains a man after he
puts on a soldier's suit death and the
company is like a death in the family
talk relieves tension
okay talk relieves tension this is a
tough one because guess what some people
when something bad happens you know what
they want to do they want to be left
alone yeah and and yet it's talk that
relieves tension too getting that out of
them which I agree with
but again you got to be tactful there's
a dichotomy you just can't go hey man I
really want to talk to you about what
happened it's like hey maybe that person
needs a little time maybe that person
needs a little space but you can't give
me too much time because they're gonna
sit there and dwell on it mmm
so pay attention the unit which fights
successful action but is without
knowledge of its success may even ensure
a great victory for some larger body and
still emerge from the battlefield with a
feeling of inferiority because it's a
complex sentence but what he's saying is
like when you make sure when your people
do something good you tell them because
there's a lot of times where people
don't people don't understand what they
did and how big of an impact it had and
that's bad mm-hmm here's a good one in
combat nothing succeeds like success the
knowledge of victory is the beginning of
a conviction of superiority just as
truly the savor of one small triumphs
will wholly drive out the bitter taste
of any number of demoralizing defeats
nothing succeeds like success now we get
the section tactical cohesion
important really think about that you
know there's a story and extreme
ownership about the boat cruise and the
boats are doing well and sometimes
people will say well you know what did
the guy that do different well the new
leader do and I always say well what he
got the team to do is get everyone in
the boat rowing the boat in the same
direction at the same time but like if
you can do that you're winning if you
can do that as a leader if you can get
everybody in the boat rowing the boat in
the same direction at the same time
you're gonna win mm-hmm and you'd be
surprised how often I see companies I
see businesses I see military units
where people are not rowing the boat in
the same direction at the same time hmm
so that's what tactical cohesion is
tactical reason is how can we get people
to be working together and here we go
getting the troops to that cohesiveness
back to the book it may be done through
one bold individual standing erect and
saying to a few others follow me we are
going on if a few rise and follow the
entire line is apt to get in motion on
the other hand if this same individual
advances alone but says nothing is
unlikely that he will have any followers
one word come makes his action tenfold
as effective as if he plunges gallantly
ahead in silence the act of moving is
initiative the act of coupling motion
with speech is thinking initiative
important very important here's talk
about getting a gun fight the first
thing you do is you hit the ground is
reestablished contact with your men
determine where they are on let them
know where you are this this happens in
business - something bad happens and we
all go into panic mode and start
focusing on our own little world as a
leader you need to say okay guys here's
what's going on here's where I am here's
what we're gonna do mm hmm
leadership leadership leadership
leadership the majority of small unit
leaders do not take any steps toward
restoring control from which alone can
come unity of action some try to contact
their men by voice or by relay a voice
during an action while the men are prone
the voice will rarely carry more than 25
feet this
unless there is a relay of all hands
under and and all hands understand what
is being attempted The Voice method is
ineffective in the SEAL Teams when
somebody yells out of command everybody
says it and it's the best it's the
coolest thing it's not the coolest thing
but it's pretty it's pretty cool when
you hear that word getting passed and
you hear the criticalness of an
important command and coming out and
everybody says it and it's just that's
what you have to do and we're so
well-trained at that that's one of the
few tactical things that you learn in
basic underwater demolition SEAL
training is you better pass the word
pass the word man it's one of those
things it's one of those things you
learn to pass the word this is this is a
great point the company coming under
fire literally begins its engagement by
falling apart so when you start getting
shot at guess what you do you get down
you can't see anyone else and you don't
know what's happening so your first
thing that happens when you get engaged
is you fall apart yeah they're after so
long as it continues to engage the
overriding problem of the commander is
the reunification of his elements this
is a great way to think of us are you
tactical leaders out there military
police firefighters this is important
think about this after the thing after
the engagement starts the overriding
problem of the commander is the Riu
reunification of his elements proper
fire support and direction are common
are among the tools which he uses in
bringing about cohesion but the
fundamental means is communication
getting his men to link up by talking to
one another and sending a long word of
what they are doing and what they have
seen now this is a very simple thing it
is so simple that it recalls the warning
from Colonel G F R Henderson in war the
simple things are the most difficult
we say that we seek initiative in our
men that is the American Way of fighting
we say that we want men who can think
and act we are just as steadfast however
in proclaiming that the supreme object
in training is to produce unity of
action these two aims are not mutually
exclusive in fact they are complementary
halves of an enlightened battle
discipline so do you catch that we want
our people to act we want our people to
act for themselves we want them to think
and act and at the same time we want
unified unit unified unity of command we
want them to be working together so we
want them to act alone and we want them
to work together there's an obviously a
dichotomy there those are the
complementary halves of an enlightened
battle discipline here we go this is
beautiful but the various curious part
of it is that lat is that training
largely ignores the sole principle which
makes these two basic ideas fully and
finally reconcilable we do not teach our
men from the day they first put on the
uniform that speech in combat is as
vital as fire in combat speech in combat
is as vital as fire in combat we do not
say to them that for a man to be able to
think straight about his tactical
situation is not enough he must
communicate his thoughts to others
before they can begin to produce unity
of action out of speech or from the
written word which is its substitute
comes all unification of strength on the
battle field and from the ladder comes
decisive action this applies to two men
serving together on an outpost it
applies equally to the battalion or the
regiment right there right there if you
can't communicate with the other people
and people don't spread the word and
your team doesn't communicate well with
each other you're not gonna be able to
join these two halves which is acting
and being decisive and being using
initiative
and cohesiveness of your unit the
question still remains what kind of
initiative is beneficial on what kind is
harmful and how may troops be might
might be taught to distinguish between
the two right so could a person on your
in your platoon takes so much initiative
that it hurts oh yes they can
I seen it many times before many times
before I've seen that so the question is
how do we know how much there's a
dichotomy right we want people to action
but we don't don't want them to take too
much action I'm glad I wrote the book
that combination yeah and here's here's
his way of trying to find that is the
soldier acting on his own to advise
others of his tactical situation or
conveying any other information which
may be of general benefit in furthering
the tactical situation of the company or
in enlisting the aid of others in
carrying out any action which will
benefit the tactical situation of the
company so you you need to take action
you need to take initiative as long as
it's benefiting the company as long as
you're and you know what we talked about
his commander's intent like you can do
whatever you want as long as it's in
support of commander's intent if it's
non supportive commander's intent we got
a problem in the army of the United
States we act towards speech as if it
were mortally as if we were mortally
afraid of it
we tell our men to think yet we never
tell them that if in combat they remain
dumb it is slow suicide slow suicide the
period between wars was an age of rapid
advancement in communications technique
radio was born the telephone was vastly
improved that teleprinter appeared in
television waited just around the corner
it all came so fast that we were struck
dumb by her own magic how brilliant is
that we were struck dumb by own magic
how many people these days are are not
becoming good communicators because
they're not interacting with people
enough because instead of talking to him
their sentiment text instead of talking
to him there they're saying him an email
yeah how is that affecting us pretty
much everybody much everybody
you got emojis coming right we got
issues I don't know that might be in the
step in the right direction right the
additional emojis additional in case you
know what it is
it does add some clarity to your
statements yeah you credit ste maybe I
need to get in the emoji game maybe but
you know that's that's a great thing to
talk about raising kids to make sure you
talk to your kids I worked with someone
once that had a kid that had like a
speech impediment mm-hmm and this kid
would just sit down and talk your ear
off with the speech impediment and and I
talked to the parent and said hey you
got one confident kid you know with the
speech impediment how did you get him to
overcome you know this this speech embed
of it or the it's not so much the speech
impediment cuz he didn't overcome and
still had it right but guess what was
gonna talk your ear off and was gonna
sit down and act professional and get
his conveys message and the response was
got him to talk to people all the time
yeah and and made him talk to people and
so that's what you do get have
conversations with your kids how's that
you know have conversations with your
people on your team how's that is that
one of the reasons why podcasts are
popular because you get to hear
conversations between people because
you're not hearing them otherwise yeah
here's he's saying this is just good
advice for this is gonna follow you
folks that are thinking about joining
the military here we go when you prepare
to fight you must prepare to talk you
must learn that speech will help you
save your situation you must be alert at
all times to let others know what is
happening to you you must use your brain
and your voice anytime that any word of
yours will help you or others you are a
tactical unit and you must think of
yourself that way don't try to win a war
or capture a hill all by yourself your
action alone means nothing or at best
very little is when you talk to others
and they join with you that your action
becomes important
gotta communicate yeah this is life
tells the story about me telling him
they use verbal commands and we've got
that story over and over again because
I've done it with so many different
people like you need to you need to use
your man voice right now like you're not
being loud enough and that was a classic
example of that
you know life trying to communicate over
the radio and people aren't really
listening cuz it's put noise in your
ears all these things happen and you
know you hit a little voice you and in
the SEAL Teams like I said we're so
trained to repeat those commands and I'm
like Lafe you got to try using verbal
commands bro you gotta try it and he
kind of looked at me like man I'm giving
the perfect brief over the radio right
now my men won't respond and so finally
you know he's you know angry life came
out he's everyone he yelled and everyone
repeated and everything happened and it
was one of those things and it's I mean
this is what 10 years ago 50 12 years
ago oh yeah but it was definitely we all
had radios on everybody every single
person had a nice radio the same radio
that's being used today with a with a
noise-canceling headset do you know what
that is yes sir okay yeah so I know he's
can't sing and so you'd think what could
be better than that what could be better
than this brand-new modern technology
with a noise-canceling headset you know
what's better than that your voice yeah
dang that's saying a lot with good voice
counseling head yeah and even though
even then the voice is better yeah well
when you got the noise-canceling headset
it it shuts off the sound so when you're
shooting your gun there's no sound
coming in now you don't hear whatever's
being told to you check all right one
final statement on that men governed by
words speech galvanizes the desire to
work together is the beginning of the
urge to get something done so learn how
to communicate just read study English
learn how to write it's gonna make you
better communicator all right there we
go to why men fight when a retrograde
movement becomes necessary in combat it
is an invitation to disaster to move
for the men are told why they are moving
if the pressure is made the fact that
that fact obvious then they still must
be told how far to go and the line or
point to which they are withdrawing must
be made clear and unmistakable otherwise
they will keep moving and all control
will be lost the spoken word is the
greatest of steadying forces in any time
of crisis think about that the spoken
word is the greatest of steadying forces
in any time of crisis an excited
lieutenant shouting get the hell out of
here and follow me to that tree they
follow me that tree line on the far side
of the creek will succeed though a
perfectly calm captain trying to bring
off the same movement but keeping his
voice calm keeping his voice down with
the result that the men do not hear him
will fail that's obvious formal language
under these circumstances is almost
unknown in the army of the United States
in fact get the hell out of here has
virtually established itself in our
jargon as the customary order said Drent
general Dragan dragomiroff a strong
moral education is the best safeguard to
solidarity of troops under fire even so
the soldier will forget or discount much
that training has taught him as the
danger mounts and fear takes hold it is
then the it is then that the voice of
the leader must cut through fear to
remind him of what is required the
reason it's the reasoned explanation of
why this is true has never been more
clearly stated than by Staff Sergeant
Pete F Dean of the 17th infantry
regiment after he'd won the Silver Star
for taking over the leading of a
demoralized platoon during the burton
island fight and here's Staff Sergeant
Pete dine I knew that the men were
afraid and careless at the same time
though some were being killed the others
would not take even average precautions
in going after the enemy installations
as
passed through them I knew they were
afraid because I was aware of my own
fear then I asked myself why it was that
we felt fear in each other and I
realized it was because all of the
leaders had quit talking I knew then
that the only way to get confidence back
into the platoon was to talk it up as a
man might do in a football game I
continued my own attack on the enemy
shelters and spider holes but there was
a difference that now begin yet that
I've now began yelling to others
watch me this is what you're supposed to
do get at it keep working keep your eyes
open
soon the platoon became collected and
began to operate methodically but I kept
talking until the end because I had
learned something new leaders must talk
if they are to lead action is not enough
a silent example will never rally men
get some or get at it in battle back to
the book in battle the voice of the
leader is always needed to call back the
men from carelessness it is their
chronic attitude in and out of danger
even in veteran troops it is not
expected it is not the expected presence
of the enemy which keeps them alert on a
hostile field but the force with which
they feel pressing them at any given
moment when fire comes against them they
sense danger from every direction unless
they are informed of the source of the
danger there is apt to occur a swift
moral transition in which they become
mentally pinned by the mere incidence of
fire I like that term mentally pinned
you don't know what's going on simple
pin down this was interesting on seven
occasions has been my part part of my
duty to investigate the sources of panic
along the battle line twice in the
Pacific and five times in Europe so
there was times where people just
panicked and left the line and he had to
investigate him and he goes into that
was how each of these incidents each of
these seven incidents got it started one
to one or two or more men made a sudden
run to the rear which others in the
vicinity did not understand but it was
the lack of information rather than the
sight of running men which was the crux
of the danger for in every case the
testimony of all witnesses clearly
developed the fact that those who
started the run and thereby spread the
fear which started the panic had a
legitimate or at least reasonable excuse
for the action it was not the sudden
motion which of itself did not did the
damage but the fact that the others
present were not kept informed got it
your people got to know what's going on
for example a sergeant in the first
Battalion 500 and second infantry was
hit through the artery during the
keratin Cosway fight On June 12th 1944
it happened in a flash one second he was
hit and the next he was running for a
first-aid station without telling his
own squad why he was getting out they
took out after him and then the line
broke others who hadn't seen the
sergeant make his - saw someone else in
flight they ran - someone said the order
is to withdraw others picked up the word
and cried it along the line withdraw
withdraw it happened just as simply as
that you can see how that happened all
day long right the term control is not
in this instance to be considered as
synonymous with the voice of authority
control is a man-to-man force on the
battlefield no matter how lowly his rank
any man who controls himself
automatically contributes to the control
of others that's legit
any man who controls himself
automatically contributes to the control
of others fear is contagious but so but
courage is not less so to the man who is
in terror and verging on panic no
influence can be more steadying than
that he sees some other man near him who
is rich retaining self-control and doing
his duty so we heard how people are just
so influenced by other people yeah I
mean you see it everywhere
personal honor is the one thing valued
more than life itself by the majority of
men the lips of the dying attest how
strongly this force influences
individual conduct in battle a young
company runner hit by a shell at Keratin
collapsed into the arms of his commander
and with his life swiftly a being said
captain this company always called me a
screw-up tell me that I wasn't tell me
that I wasn't one this time the captain
replied no son you sure weren't and the
board died with a smile on his face
but while an army is a collection of
individuals it is also a crowd under
pressure and under pressure it tends to
ever to revert to crowd form the seeds
of panic are always present in troops so
long as they are in the midst of
physical danger the form of which
changes moment to moment in the majority
of men the retention of self-discipline
under the conditions of the battlefield
depends on the maintaining of an
appearance of discipline within the unit
so obviously with businesses man with
businesses you'll get a business that
like people or squared away that's how
they roll in everyone act squared away
then you get some people that aren't and
that's the that's the image that's the
culture of the company and no one
squared away hmm should the latter begin
to dissolve so should the discipline
within the unit begin to dissolve only a
small minority of the most Hardy
individuals will retain self-control the
others cannot stand fast if the
circumstances appear to justify flight
when other men flee the social pressure
is lifted and the average soldier will
respond as if he has been given a free
release from duty free knows that his
personal failure is made inconspicuous
by the general dissolution - it is a
normal tendency in troops that they will
drift rearward from the fire line unless
they are being given an active direction
but it is just as normal that they will
reverse
selves quickly and return to their duty
if given a firm order by someone whom
they know yeah and have you ever been a
situation we just like put outward like
like just something stupid like um like
you'll be in a store or something and
people people will be like not knowing
hey they're just someone say hey there's
a register over here mm-hmm
or like you're out waiting in a wine at
a at a public event of some kind you
know hey wrap this thing around wrap the
line around yeah and everyone just does
it yeah yeah like it so I think this is
kind of what you're talking about to you
like at the airport okay all super late
DC in with the wrong Airport last minute
last second by the way anyway I'm
standing in the TSA line I see super
long by the way when I see super long I
mean like like you ain't gonna make it
flat yeah this is long like a long line
like there was a crowd so I'm standing
lying I'm like you know when you're
in a hurry you're always looking for
little shortcuts and I'll violate a few
rules you know to get there quicker so
I'm on the lookout everyone else just
cruising just falling in line literally
so I look and I see a weird sort of line
start off kind of forming mmm way
shorter to like the kind like I can I
can Lily literally walk about 15 meters
ahead to the end of this weird little
line for me everyone sees it it's a
little line but it's kind of like one of
those things that go it's not what we're
doing and I think the lines make it even
more psychologically rigid you know
where it's like we're in line and to get
out of line that's the kind of a big
deal yeah well says it's the social what
is he calling it here the social you get
the release from social duty right yeah
oh yeah yeah everyone's saying in line
and you're just doing what everyone else
there's like a social pressure to stay
in line yes exactly right so but boom i
man I was gonna miss that so I asked Oh
how's this I asked the guy not like in
that line cuz it's way ahead I asked the
guy in the next line who was like maybe
two three people ahead
but in a different light I was like is
that another line and he you know he
says he said yeah it is he goes yeah it
is like oh I just go he already know it
but then he was like standing it but he
didn't do it probably for it from that
social pressure so of course I go and
then everyone falls brah I look behind
everyone I fear like a commotion behind
me but it's just so many people feeling
it that's how freaking leaving from the
flight but literally like what ten
seconds probably your clothes yeah this
is a again I kind of covered this moment
hate it one more time
individual stragglers had almost no
combat value and inducted into a strange
organization the majority of them were
unwilling to join any such solid unit
which still facing the enemy the
minority even after being given food and
a little rest took their place in line
but the moment the new unit came under
enemy pressure the individuals quit
their ground and ran rearward or sought
cover behind somewhere behind the combat
line so this is what IRA talked about
you get a new person and they don't know
anyone they're not gonna do their job on
the other hand this is important for
businesses on the other hand that was
not true of gun crews squad groups or
platoon which had been routed from their
original ground and separated from their
parent unit but had managed in some way
to hold together during a fall back upon
being inducted into a strange company
they tended to fight as vigorously as
any element in the command which they
had newly joined and would frequently
set an example of initiative and
courageous action beyond what had been
asked of them think about that keep your
keep your little elements together mmm I
used to be real big on that you got your
little fire teams yeah and I would
always try and keep the little fire team
integrity keep that fire team integrity
and these would be like in this is in a
seal platoon there's four there's four
fire teams and a task unit you know
there's eight fire teams try and keep
these gonna still know each other but
they're gonna do a little bit better
they just keep that fire team integrity
know each other they already know what's
up yeah
in our striving for a system of
discipline which recognizes in theory
though the theories offered and ignored
in practice that the relationships
within our army should be based upon
intimate understanding between officers
and men rather than familiarity between
them on self-respect
rather than fear and above all on
uniting comradeship self-respect rather
than fear this is they have destroyed
the name and tradition of old and
honored regiments with the stroke of a
pen for convenience sake they have
uprooted the names and numbers which had
identity with a certain soil and move
them willy-nilly to another soil they
have moved men around as if they were
pegs and nothing counted but a
specialist classification number they
have become fillers of holes rather than
architects of human spirit that's bold
isn't it yes if you like them so
sometimes in the army then the army does
this more than anyone else I believe
they'll just like take a unit that's
been around for 122 years and fought in
all kinds of wars and just disband them
they're done just get rid of them hmm
and just and sometimes they bring them
back thankfully but that's not a good
idea there's a certain power in
tradition right there's a certain power
interested there's a when they formed up
SEAL Team 5 they took they took SEAL
team or sorry underwater demolition team
11 and they disbanded it and basically
reformed it as SEAL Team 5 but if you
look at the the symbol of SEAL Team 5
there's a Setting Sun and on the Setting
Sun is the number 11 you can see it
going down little bull fact for you UDT
pretty cool but they at least kept that
tradition alive right least kept that
tradition alive yeah
and yes this idea of fillers of holes
rather than architects of human spirit
you got to think about what you're doing
with little units when you start
breaking them up and move from people
around there's this there's
relationships there that you're messing
with
you might not be doing a good thing just
because this guy has a certain
qualification I'll put him over there
therein lies a great weakness and we
have suffered from it through every war
for it must ever remain that acquisition
of a truer knowledge of the nature of
man in war will suffice very little if
put to work only by the local commander
on limited ground so everybody's got to
understand that there's human beings
working here that you're dealing with
him that you have to be an architect of
the human spirit that again leaves too
much to chance and puts too high a
premium on the virtues and talents of
the average leader what is needed
primarily if we are to go forward the
policy stemming from the top which are
based not upon slide-rule calculations
but on knowledge of the human heart next
chapter the aggressive will I like this
little section morale is the thinking of
an army it is the whole complex body of
an Army's thought the way it feels about
the soil and about the people from which
it Springs the way that it feels about
their cause and their politics is
compared with other causes and other
politics the way that it feels about its
friends and allies as well as its
enemies about its commanders and
goldbricks about food and shelter duty
and leisure militarism and civilian ism
freedom and slavery work and want
weapons and comradeship bunk fatigue and
drill discipline and disorder life and
death God and the devil that's a big
that's a big that's what he's saying
like you've got human beings and the
morale of the army is all of that stuff
combined together you have to account
for it the definition cut through one of
the oldest myths in the military book
that morale comes from discipline the
process is precisely the reverse
ooh discipline is the product of morale
right I never really thought about that
too much
how's your morale if you have good
morale you're gonna have better
discipline if your morale is weak what
happens your discipline goes out the
window the soldier needs a sound and
vigorous body if he is to contend in
modern war but this itself should be the
object rather than the perfecting of him
and drills not even remotely related to
use of his weapons out of a mistaken and
obsolescent notion that they somehow
improve his discipline there is no such
time for method for this method so doing
stuff just to do it to like improve your
discipline does not what we're talking
about here beyond the basic physical
requirement the essential is that he be
given the freedom to think with a clear
mind which freedom can be his only when
he becomes convinced that the army and
particularly the army as represented by
his immediate superiors is doing
everything possible for his welfare you
gotta care about your people that's what
that's what mook said that's what that's
what general Mookie Amma said you care
about your people like hundred percent
agree soldiers can endure hardship most
of their training is directed toward
conditioning them for unusual privation
and exertion but no power on earth can
reconcile them to what common sense says
is unnecessary hardship which might have
been avoided by greater intelligence in
their superiors that is awesome if your
your people do all kinds of didn't take
all kinds of punishment for you but if
they see that there's a way you could
have avoiding punishment for them and
you didn't do it because you were dumb
they're gonna rebel against you the more
intelligent the more intelligent the
soldier the more likely it is that he
will see as a sign see that as a sign of
indiscipline up above and we'll answer
it the same way so if the upper chain of
commands dropping the ball guess what's
gonna happen lower chain of what we're
dropping
- nothing more radical is suggested here
than that the leader who would make
certain of the fundamental soundness of
his operation cannot do better than
concentrate his attention on his men
that's a bold statement there's nothing
better you can do than concentrate your
attention on your men if you want
something to be successful concentrate
on your people there is no other
worthwhile Road the do they do only
themselves who believe that there is a
brand of military efficiency which
consists in moving smartly expediting
papers and achieving perfection in
formations while at the same time
sliding or ignoring the human nature of
those whom they command the art of
leading and operations large or small is
the art of dealing with humanity and
working diligently on behalf of men of
being sympathetic with them but equally
of insisting that they make a square
facing toward their own problems these
are the real basis of commanders major
calculations that's just a awesome that
whole thing the art of leading dealing
with humanity working diligently on
behalf of your men being sympathetic
with them and at the same time dichotomy
insisting that they make a square facing
toward their own problems boom
men who have been in battle know from
firsthand experience that when the chips
are down a man fights to help the man
next to him next to him just as a
company fights to keep pace with its
flanks things have to be that simple and
ideal does not become tangible at the
moment of firing a volley or charging a
hill having already suggested that the
thinking bayonets can never be
subordinated by the routine methods of a
discipline which is based largely in
mechanical procedures I will add that no
leader will ever fail his troops nor
will they fail him who leads them in
respect for the discipline life
between these two things undisciplined
in itself and a personal faith in the
military value of discipline lies all
the difference between military maturity
and mediocrity a salute from a willing
from an unwilling soldier is meaningless
as the moving of a leaf on a tree it is
a sign only that the subject has been
caught by a gust of wind but a salute
from the man who takes pride in the
gesture because he feels privileged to
wear the uniform having found this
service good is an act of the highest
military virtue one further fact that
needs to be stressed about the character
of those officers whose capacity could
be measured in the efficiency of their
companies while they were scrupulous in
the care of their men they were not wet
nurses they treated their subordinates
as men they did not regard them as
adolescents and they did not employ the
classroom manner in dealing with them
individually or in the mass that was an
important part of their hold upon the
men the men prized a commander the more
if he looks and acts the part of a
soldier but the characteristic of a fine
appearance will but betray him the
sooner if he has no real kinship with
the men so he this dichotomy you got to
take care of your men but you're not a
wet nurse you don't treat them like
little kids the characteristics which
are required in the minor in the minor
commander if he is to prove capable of
preparing men for and leading them
through the shock of combat with high
credit may therefore be briefly
described as one diligence in the care
of men so here's the characteristics
number one diligence and the care of men
number two administration of all
organizational affairs such as
punishments and promotions according to
a standard of resolute justice number
three military bearing number four a
basic understanding of the simple fact
that soldiers wish to
think of themselves as soldiers and that
all military information is nourishing
to their spirits and their lives number
five courage creative intelligence and
physical fitness
number six innate respect for the
dignity of the position and the work of
other men I'm gonna tell you those are
some good rules some good things to
think about if you're in a leadership
position here's a little commentary and
it was written in 1947 might still be
true today it is my belief that there is
no more hurtful doctrine put before our
people today than that the army should
duplicate the arrangements which
obtained within the civil society
slavishly imitating the latter's
comforts social customs and ideas of
regulating justice and insisting on no
higher standards of personal
responsibility for its people
so hey guess what the military is not
the civilian world and we shouldn't be
trying to make it that way
the military's the military that's 1947
he's saying that I'm gonna have to say I
agree in my opinion and I do not say
this lightly the fault in our
disciplinary level during World War 2
was not primarily that the discipline of
the ranks needed to be more relaxed but
that the discipline of a considerable
percentage of our officers needed to be
tightened for this simple reason insofar
as his ability to mold the character of
troops is concerned the qualifying test
of an officer is the judgment placed
upon his soldierly abilities by those
who serve under him
you can only mold your troops if they
judge you worthy of molding them think
about that for a minute if they do not
deem him fit to command he cannot train
them to obey thus we're slackness is
tolerated and officership it
a direct invitation to disobedience and
as disobedience multiplies all
discipline disappears Allah I love this
little section here no officer can
command unless he is certain of himself
and confident that his orders are likely
to lead to success on the other hand
command does not create its own magic
men who are filled with the spirit of
disobedience will break the heart and
ruin the character of the finest officer
who ever lived maybe gonna deal with
some rabble rousers out there we're
dealing some tough cookies mm-hmm the
way in which the loss of moral incentive
is reflected in the tactical behavior
enough troops was thoughtfully expressed
many years ago by the British teacher
Colonel G F R Henderson
when troops once realized their
inferiority they can go they can no
longer be depended on if attacking they
refuse to advance if defending they
abandon all hope of resistance it is not
the losses they have suffered but those
they expect to suffer that affect them
consequently unless discipline and
national spirit spirit are of superior
quality and unless the soldier is
animated by something higher than the
habit of mechanical obedience panic
shirking and wholesale surrender will be
the ordinary features of the campaign
pretty harsh warning nothing more
unfortunate can happen to the commander
than to come to be regarded by his
subordinates as unapproachable for such
a reputation isolates him from the main
problems of command as well as its chief
rewards so you got to be approachable as
a leader the same there's nothing more
unfortunate than being regarded as
unapproachable it is back to the book is
never a waste of time for the commander
to talk to his people about their
problems here's the good people ask me I
get all the junior leaders from the
military from the civilian sector from
everywhere and they asked me what am I
supposed to do to the young officer
who's conscious of his own
and is anxious to do something about it
I can suggest nothing better than to
make a habit of full physical
participation that is instead of
watching the squad or platoon work out a
problem and either directing or
criticizing its action let him pick up a
weapon relieve one man in the group then
let himself be the one commanded until
the conclusion of the operation is this
course of contact beneath the dignity of
the American officer certainly not so
get what was it get in the game get in
the game in the United States service we
are tending to forget because of the
effective motorization that the higher
value of discipline of the road march in
other days that it was that wasn't that
it harden muscles but that short of
combat it was the best method of
separating the men from the boys what
was cool is get back to the little road
march action best method for separating
a men from the boys is the road march
this is true today despite all the new
conditions imposed by high-velocity
warfare hard road march is the most
satisfactory training test of the moral
strength of the individual man the great
advantage of the gain in moral force
through all forms of physical training
is that it is onion unconscious gain all
forms of physical training are you give
you an unconscious gain of moral force
let that propel your work out tomorrow
morning willpower determination mental
poise and mental control all March
hand-in-hand with the general health and
well-being of the man fatigue will beat
men down as quickly as any other
condition for for fatigue brings fear
with it
there was no quicker way to lose a
battle than to lose it on the road for
lack of adequate preliminary hardening
in troops such a condition cannot be
redeemed by the resolve of a commander
who insists on driving troops an extra
mile beyond their general level of
physical endurance that's important to
remember you if you've got people that
aren't ready it doesn't matter how much
you try and make them do something
they're not physically capable of doing
it
that's the reality extremes of this sort
make men rebellious and hateful of the
command and thus strike at the tactical
efficiency from two directions at once
for when men resent a commander they
will not fight as willingly for him and
when their bodies are spent their nerves
are gone in this state the soldiers
every act is mechanical he is reduced to
that automatisms of mind which destroys
physical response his courage is killed
his intellect falls asleep truly then it
is killing men with kindness not to
insist upon physical standards during
trainer during training which will give
them a maximum fitness for the
extraordinary stresses of campaigning in
a war killing men truly killing men with
kindness not to have them physically
ready as the body is hardened so must
the mind be steadily informed so that
the soldier will take a reasoning view
not only of the privations of the field
but of that which is being attempted
once we depart from the ideal of
automatic response as the condition most
likely to produce unity of action in
battle
the only substitute for it lies in the
possibility that more and more men in
the ranks can be trained to see and
think through the haze of battle in
unison with their commanders you can see
you can see I mean when you read about
face
there's the Hackworth this is what
Hackworth did know this is how hack was
rolled hmm fact back to the book why is
the will of the military commander
deemed more decisive of success than the
will of leadership in any other calling
clearly it is because the inertia
frictions and confusions of the forces
of the battlefield make all positive
action more difficult and yet the
principles which win intelligent
man-to-man cooperation applies equally
in all circumstances the same rules work
on the battlefield as in an office
that's why we go with something called a
chillon front
the wheel does not operate in a vacuum
it cannot be imposed successfully if it
runs counter to reason things are not
done war primarily because a man wills
it they are done because they are doable
okay this is a really important little
section and you know I I you know I talk
about force of will sometime you gotta
make something happen force a will mmm
but there's a very important enough call
to caveat to that and we're about to get
into this caveat so to say that again
things not done in war things are not
done in war primarily because a man
wills it they are done because they are
doable the limits for the commander in
battle are defined by the general
circumstance when he asks what he asks
of his men must be consistent with the
possibilities of the situation that
might seem like common sense right hey I
can't ask you to do anything that cannot
be done back to the book what can be
successfully willed must first be
clearly seen and understood if amid the
confusion of battle the commander sees
what is required by the situation if
amid the miscarriage of arrangements and
other assailing doubts of other men he
measures the means of doing it and if he
then gives his order and holds his men
to their duty this is the ultimate
triumph of the will on the battlefield
to reflect on this thought is to note
that he exercises his will
far less upon his men than upon himself
should he on the other hand attempt to
will that which his men know cannot be
done or feel unanimously is utterly
beyond reason or should he base his
order on assumptions which they
recognize as false his will becomes
temporarily without power and cannot
help the situation this is one of those
things where people think I'm just gonna
I'm gonna tell him to do it and we'll
see what they can get done right like no
they're not gonna think I'm gonna see
that they can't do it and it's gonna say
we're not gonna try yeah make your goals
realistic make them not not just
realistic I'll make them them achievable
there is scarcely any commander with any
time in combat but has had his
experience of having willing troops
becomes suddenly unresponsive because
his facts were not straight so sometimes
the troops aren't gonna do what you
wanted to do even though you have this
strong will they're not gonna do why is
that here we go it happened to
Lieutenant Colonel
hwil Cunard during the night advance of
first Battalion 500 first parachute
infantry against the German held Dutch
village in September 1944 the village of
shingle which I have praised elsewhere
in this book as one of the most
brilliant battalion actions of the war
the column had advanced only 500 yards
beyond its outpost line when it came
under machine gun and anti-tank fire
canard heard some of the fire clipping
the branches of the tree above his head
and judged it was all going high but the
lead company had stopped and the men had
jumped for the ditches he ran forward
shouting to the men keep going keep
going
that fire is high but his personal
advance had no effect not a man stirred
so this is a incredibly like seasoned
meat tough well-trained group and he's
telling them and he's personally leading
them forward saying go go we gotta go
don't worry that fires high but it has
no effect not a man stirred back to the
book within a moment he understood why
he had failed from one of the ditches a
rifleman answered him if you think the
fire is high colonel come over here
we've had eight men hit in the legs so
you've got to think about what is
actually possible
the supreme trial of the commander in
war lies in his ability to overcome the
weaknesses of human nature in the face
of danger and these are the matters
which he cannot know in full unless he
is served with men where danger lies
chapter 12 men under fire to those that
have known the firing line it would
scarcely be necessary to point out that
morale and combat is never a steady
current force but a rapidly oscillating
wave whose variations are both
immeasurable and unpredictable it is in
this respect chiefly the rapidity and
capriciousness of its variations that
the morale that the morale problem in
the zone of fire differs from that from
that of a rear area soldiering a band of
men go may go through a terrible
engagement take its losses bravely and
then become wholly demoralized in the
hour in which it must bury its own dead
a regiment threaded to utter objection
by a protracted stay in the lines may
find its fighting spirit again in a six
hour respite during which the men are
deal oust and giving a chant given a
change of underwear a battalion
advancing boldly may be brought in check
because its commander did the disservice
of going too far forward and getting
himself killed within sight of the ranks
a platoon may charge and capture an
enemy he'll elde Hill losing half its
numbers in doing so then run down the
hill again because one of its own
artillery shells landed too close and
hit one man so that the morale of the
troops is constantly at at risk of going
up or going down the near presence of
death and the prospect of meeting it at
the next moment movement and many
curious and contrary ways many men many
men seem to change character under the
guns the life of hardship and of danger
gives new strength to the truly strong
and greater weakness to the truly weak
so combat is gonna have an effect on
people it's gonna amplify their
situation mm-hmm what normal man would
deny that some of the fullest and
fairest days of his life have been spent
at the front or that the sky ever seems
more blue or the air more bracing than
when there is just a hint of danger in
the air this is an important thing for
leaders to understand the man who cannot
bring himself to trust the judgment and
good faith of other men cannot command
very long he will soon break under the
unnecessary strain he puts on himself
sleeplessness nervous irritation and
loss of self-control will be his will be
his lot until he is at last found
totally unfit the ideal relationship
between a commander and his subordinate
is nowhere better Illustrated than in a
passage from the letter of instruction
wherein grant told chef Sherman to
proceed to the destruction of Johnston's
army quote I do not propose to lay down
for you a plan of campaign but simply to
lay down the work it is desirable to
have done and leave you free to execute
it in your own way some decentralized
command right there this is another good
one when a company is stopped by
physical shock restoration of its
movement becomes a problem for the
battalion when a company is stopped by
psychological shock the continuing of
the advance remains the problem of the
company commander and here's some
advance as some examples of that
diffusion of the company over to widest
sector a retrograde movement by
supporting weapons such as armor the
death of a well-loved officer light
losses from friendly supporting fire the
appearance of some new and unexpected
weapon in the enemy sector such are a
few of the causes of psychological shock
the local treatments are as many and is
very
as are the diseases with respect to the
effect of friendly fire hitting among
troops however it is to be observed that
if circumstances leave any room for
doubt as to the source the men will jump
to the conclusion that they are being
victimized by their own guns it is in
instances where it is unmistakable that
they have been hurt by their own fire
however the commander is ill advised to
lie to them they will usually learn the
truth later on and when they do it
strikes a blow to his prestige the
experienced combat soldier knows that
such occasional accidents are part of
battle and he accepts them as such
but he cannot make any good judgment to
the realization that his commander is
either a fool or a liar no gain ever
comes from being slick with troops from
acting deviously instead of forthrightly
from posing as having superior knowledge
or from being secretive or discounting
the common sense of the majority see a
lot of people do that they discount the
common sense they think they're gonna
get away with that with with trying to
the troops and it doesn't work
the most common cause of psychological
shock however is partial victory the
adage that the weakest point follows
success is a fundamental truth of minor
tactics and the danger is always
greatest when success is too easily won
success is disarming tension is the
normal state of mind and body in combat
when the tension suddenly relaxes
through the winning of a first objective
troops are apt to be pervaded by a sense
of extreme well-being and there is apt
to ensue laxness in all its forms and
with all its dangers
[Music]
he he hammers this home it might be well
to speak of the importance of enthusiasm
kindness courtesy and justice which are
the safeguards of honor and the tokens
of mutual respect respect between man
and man this last there must be if they
are to go forward together prosper in
one another's company and find strength
in the bonds of mutual exert us and
experience a common velocity in the
relationship between the leader and the
lead loyalty is the big thing
the greatest battle asset of all but no
man ever wins the loyalty of troops by
preaching loyalty no man ever wins the
loyalty of troops by preaching loyalty
it is given him by them as he proves his
possession of the other virtues the
doctrine of a blind loyalty to
leadership is a selfish and futile
military dogma except insofar as it is a
noble by a higher loyalty in all ranks
to truth and decency war is - war is
much too brutal a business to have room
for brutal leading in the end it's only
effect can be to corrode the character
of men and when character is lost all is
lost the bully and the sadist serve only
to further encumber an army their
subordinates must waste precious time
clearing away the wreckage that they
make the good company has no place for
the officer who would rather be right
than beloved for the time will quickly
come when he walks alone and in battle
no man may succeed in solitude that's
worth repeating the good company has no
place for the officer officer who would
rather be right than be loved we talked
about that when Jordan was off man you
don't need to be right when you're
dealing with your significant other no
that's not important
I have known a few brutes in battle
whose talents were so limited that they
could no try no other means of command
than the abusive men but I have yet to
see one who did a good job of holding
his command together when the going
became rough and in the ranks fear of
the enemy began to eclipse fear of the
man up top now he here comes the
dichotomy because he's talking about all
these kindness and courtesy and justice
and then he says ruggedness ruggedness
toughness ah these are quite different
things so long as they are only the
outer reflection of an inner
determination and so long as the inner
fire is tempered by a heart having real
compassion for men these are the best
hands for the business they will win the
hearts of other men and will stimulate
their valour these others will try to be
like them for is a truth not to be
denied that the rugged way is the
natural way in battle dichotomy right
there it tells this quick story there
comes to mind one last picture from the
same campaign the scene is stonewalled
Fort Mont Barry the last obstacle
barring entry into Brest
a battalion of the 116th Infantry
Regiment under Major Tom Dallas has had
the fort invested for three days but the
defenders have withdrawn to within the
inner walls and will not surrender the
infantry fire cannot get at them the
ports have been flamed but without
visible effect finally Dallas acts were
three tons of TNT to blow the walls he
has given one ton assisted by the
infantry the engineers lay the charge in
a gallery under the wall the work
completed
Dallas is ready to give the orders then
he remembers on the night before the
battalion had attacked and lieutenant
durwood sea settles had been killed in
the moat
there had been no chance to
for the body it is still there and will
be crushed by the falling masonry so the
demolition is held up and Dallas asks
for a volunteer to go down to the moat
under fire and bring out the body a
young lieutenant named Kelton responds
in a few minutes
Kelton returns with his burden he says
to Dallas we are ready now
Dallas replies ready then blow them all
to hell the charge goes off the earth
shakes the walls collapse with a roar
there is a stunned silence from within
the fort
Dallas stands there for a few seconds
and the tears fall as he looks down at
the body of his dead officer and that is
loyalty close this out with a couple
more things in every action large or
small is decided by what happens up
there on the line with where men take
the final chance of life or death though
I would not for a moment contend that
modern war can be fought in one without
vigorous thought and action on the
homefront I deny absolutely that these
things can vouchsafe military victory
anymore now than in the days when men
fought with spears and crossbows any who
look at war and think otherwise are
siting through the wrong end of the
telescope they have become deceived by
the Vadnais of vastness of the National
preparation how differently they would
see things if it became their duty to
measure the thin margins between victory
and defeat on the field itself the great
victories of the United States have
pivoted on the acts of courage and
intelligence of a very few individuals
the time always comes in battle when the
decisions of statesmen and of general
generals can no longer affect the issue
and when it is not within the power of
our national wealth to change
the balance decisively victory is never
achieved prior to that point it can only
be won after the battle has been
delivered into the hands of men who move
in imminent danger of death courage is
the real driving force in human affairs
and that every worthwhile action comes
of some man daring what others fear to
attempt a man who is willing to fight
for his country his final is finally the
full custodian of its security if there
were no willing men no power and
government could ever rally the masses
of the unwilling two men who have been
long in battle and have thought about it
deeply there comes at last the awareness
of this ultimate responsibility that one
man must go ahead so that a nation may
live and so the final and greatest
reality that national strength lies only
in the hearts and spirits of men the
Army Navy and Air Force are not the
guardians of its national security the
tremendous problem of the future is
beyond their capacity to solve the
search begins at the cradle where the
mother makes the decision either to tie
her child to her apron strings or two
rear him as a man it continues through
years of schooling when children are
taught either to place personal
interests uppermost or to think in terms
of their responsibilities toward their
society their country and all of mankind
and there you go strength lies in the
hearts and spirits of men and freedom
lies in the courage and the discipline
of daring to attempt what others fear
and I think that that reflects not just
the strength and freedom of Nations of
countries but also of individuals we are
ultimately responsible for ourselves for
our own freedom for our own security it
is on us and I think that is one of the
on the most valuable lessons to learn
from SLA Marshall and you know
unwillingly he also taught us a lesson
about being truthful and honest which he
was not and had he listened to some of
his own teachings he might not have made
that mistake to tarnish his reputation
it's not worth it he failed to listen to
his own lesson
and maybe that's the last thing we
learned is that we do just don't just
don't talk the talk just don't preach
but walk the walk and live the life live
correctly and follow the rules that you
set for yourself and then you go and you
live with the courage and the strength
and the discipline so that you can truly
free your mind and I think that's all
I've got for tonight
echo Charles yes so speaking of strength
and discipline and walking the walk and
walking the walk and living the life
staying on the path maybe you've got
some things that could help us uphold
the personal standards that we set for
ourselves yes I do
I can I will SLA Marshall taught us a
lesson he didn't want to teach us about
that didn't he yeah one of those things
were I was kind of getting into it you
know like that's true yeah that's and
then look kind of like how you mentioned
if I'm like wait but this guy but then
you know it's like it's the dichotomy
yeah it's the dichotomy there's an
unfortunate dichotomy yeah see that's if
this guy if this guy if we just knew
about his normal military record and you
never said he'd any other stuff this
would have so much more impact yeah the
fact that he lied just just it just
hurts it hits all those - it jammed him
up as echo Charles would say but you
know if you can how is it we're not
throw the baby out with the bathwater
yeah there's some good stuff in there
yeah I'll tell you what is possible is
for us to stay on the path
and in that path on that path is
jiu-jitsu of course right better should
be should be in my plane you actually
said today that that was one quarter of
your life it is in your life yes one
quarter of the things you do is
jiu-jitsu you know all of the total
things that I do you know yeah important
things because there's things that
aren't on that list like at the grocery
store well go in the grocery store does
facilitate one of the other things in my
life so you're saying it's not one of
the things it is not one of the things
no that's like saying oh breathing you
know well broad breathing's not a party
life well yeah but it facilitates other
things okay so if that's the case does
origin facilitate jiu-jitsu it does
which is good right yes so eat food and
you gotta have origin yes check big time
okay so origin okay origin main calm
this is where you can get your geek for
jujitsu if you haven't got one already
go get one
there's people out there who don't know
any other guy except for junkie actually
someone contacted me it was like hey I
realize you know origin is the key to
get but before I buy one would you
consider donating one to my cause I
think they're like saving up for you
know cuz sometimes that's how you know
you save up for you gear whatever so I'm
thinking on one hand the dichotomy sure
I'm never using these other keys again I
wouldn't know I see but on the other
hand why would I want to distill a
substandard yogi undo someone's just
starting by the way so it's like boom
they got there but then again now yeah
okay
I probably will you know all right well
that's neither here nor there
nonetheless the point is if you want to
get a good keep all made in America
various types I'm sure I had when we
were in Maine so after the camp was over
a Pete and I were at the factory we were
just getting stuff done and planning and
everything but he went into depth on
weaving the fabric on the loom and
everything huh bro
it's a crazy I've got full understanding
though yeah and it's awesome yeah it's
awesome to see it's interesting to sit
to watch Pete get into it just let him
go oh yeah for sure oh man this that's
why these things are like so delt when
you get that's why that's why that's why
the company is where it is yes because
without that passion for him for the
team like when you talk to anyone on the
team at origin they're like wanting of
this stuff to be awesome and so that's
why it's that way yeah yes so it's cool
if you ever get a chance to go to the
factory up there it's worth checking out
yeah sure cuz it isn't just like Oh a
factor it's like a factory you can come
hang out there's kind of lose like a
would you like a pro show yeah you can
go in there and then it's like kind of
open you can talk to the people it's
good man that's good yeah
so yeah oh yeah I would recommend that
too in Farmington Maine by the way so
where it is anyway also on there is
joggers and rash guards and clothes yep
for sure for sure the rash guards
compression compression gear yeah you
got supplements as well so we got four
supplements joint warfare which is gonna
help your joints for a bunch of
different reasons I get awesome
compliments about that that I'm stoked
on that krill oil also gonna help your
joints and it's gonna help you just the
whole life mhm mhm and then you got the
discipline which I'm on a lot of
discipline right now and I didn't even
realize we were in a three-hour podcast
at this moment in time through and we
recorded a couple other podcasts today
yeah shorter podcast but podcast
nonetheless you over here getting the
upper hand on life yes I did the three
scoops of discipline I'm doing I have to
feel like I understand it so this one
free life pre-mission pre-function yeah
pre-function free yes free get some any
format mental format physical format
my middle daughter took the AC tees
mm-hmm on Saturday mm-hmm
and she came home she kind of fueled her
up on some discipline before going in
and she came back fired up yeah she was
like yeah no I thought so I was oh
and I was like yeah you just ya
discipline yeah so many schools are you
ever and you know she's not as big as me
no I still gave up I'm down for the
discipline by the way yeah yeah it's a
it's kind of a double effect and I could
see how that could be especially if
you're going into some situation like a
test yeah or even like a jujitsu
situation whatever you for sure yeah and
then even afterwards when you remember
how like solid you where you're like it
kind of gets you fired up yeah yes it's
like a double-layered you got fired up
because you got fired you like that yes
I do very much
and oh yeah and the last thing is and
it's not the lights the last but
certainly not the least is is something
called mulk yeah if you wanna know what
Moke is it's real simple
Mulk is more I mean more pancakes
straight up okay so going down this
rabbit hole just making most everything
okay here's the thing I'm sketch about
the pancakes right so there's my don't
even like I straight-up don't even like
pancakes okay at all
yeah for me to even think about making
Molk pancakes maybe it's something I
could try because maybe I would like it
well if you don't like here's the thing
I'm not a monk pancake like expert at
all okay so tell people how to make it
well here's the thing is how I made them
okay so I get tasked with wait were they
good because they weren't good and let's
not talk about it oh they're real good
so did you put maple syrup Oh maple
syrup come from origin Maine negative
okay that's good no I can't say that I
don't think so not that I know but well
okay on Saturdays or Sundays depending I
get I make pancakes only one day and
it's for the kids and all this stuff so
she's a thing oh that's cool hey you
know I'm gonna do for you kids this
weekend I'm gonna give you a bunch of
carbohydrates and poison you yeah
in my defense maple syrup I got these or
my wife got these paleo but it's pain
okay was that almond powder or something
okay Haley okay so boom I go in and you
know pancake mix it's like a certain
kind of mix to create like a pancake mix
I could I could easily jam this whole
thing up easily and I'm not making it
just for me as an experiment my kids are
stressed awake life yeah but I give them
open cakes they're not correct
I will hear about it or and the whole
thing is a flop yeah I guess technically
I just make great clear pancakes later
but it wasn't about that right then
there I was trying to deliver big time
so I can just start throwing random
ingredients in a recipe in the back of
it so this is what I did it called for a
cup and a third of pancake mix I just
put like a little less in a cup and then
you know a third a little bit over the
third cup Molk mm-hmm milk in there a
little bit of water some MCT oil I put
in it calls for like you input butter
and I did blue butter like grass-fed
butter by the way and eggs yeah yeah so
you put a egg boom mix it all up
pancakes oh I put chocolate chips in the
form of a happy face too and yeah so did
that yeah more like a sad face a your
house but boom I make them a little bit
darker obviously because the chocolate
it was the chocolate peanut butter by
the way it wasn't the mean cakes yeah
well yeah there is darker ground yeah
not the mint too by the way I think that
you're risking jamming up pancakes for
the mint I think I don't know no I
didn't do it anyway yeah okay more good
boom maple syrup
boom big hit kids like that kids didn't
know but they it had the peanut butter
kind of flavor in there it's good yeah
yeah so that's the market normally goes
with milk or you can put it in water but
that's like a ham sandwich whereas if
you put milk in there it's like a done
initiation what it did
I put two drops of vanilla in there Oh
Andy Andy Burke came home from camp and
we were just talking about camp and it
was cool you know he's a cabin awesome
meeting everyone and training in blah
blah blah and he's like you know what I
really like though I was like oh my this
is my first time having more
surprisingly good like right we knew
that yeah and I was like ah you you do
you think people don't believe it is
your instinct to think oh this is some
kind of a supplement it's gonna taste
bad I just have to deal with it but this
one maybe taste okay
and therefore you know these guys are
talking up but the real the reality is
the reality is it's good it's like a
desert straight up you know it's like a
milkshake you know that's the milk and
has it's good for you that's the crazy
thing
all right so cool that you get all that
stuff at origin main dot-com yes and
also chocolate store it's called choco
store and this is where you can get
shirts hoodies rash other rash guards
more more skewed towards the path the
message anyway there's some cool stuff
on there if you want to represent
discipline equals freedom cuz discipline
does equal freedom by the way mm-hmm
that's one of those things like you can
think about that for like 20 days and
it'll it'll make more and more sense
over 320 days and then after 2 years and
in my case 3 years makes even more sense
you see it everywhere just lingers
really yeah and so it does and if you
want to represent jungle store.com
professor you can get the stuff cool
stuff on there some new stuff on there
too by the way really yes
ie Oh cuz you always making stuff I
don't even know about you centralized
command style well we got a few novelty
items you know what I mean is that yeah
you know I'm assuming if I have it
correctly it's just something that's
pretty cool you know gotta go in there
and find out I mean awful the items sure
you think people are gonna really think
people on the path are out spending
their hard-earned money on novelty items
is that what's going on uh well there's
always layers so it's not just novelty
it's still you're still representing big
time hunters hair but some one of the
layers is just quite novel in my
anyway go there chuckles door comms -
yeah we're doing that's why you know I'm
gonna check check chocolate or calm yeah
anyway hats on there as well a lot of
cool stuff anyway
chocolate or calm good way to support
good way to stay on the path it's just
good all around good hey did you see uh
what was it
what's his name um not what's the name
but the the you know the Nike commercial
right you know the Nike commercials been
in the news right yeah whatever
and Theo von was like hey oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah do put that out what's up do
you know what that is maybe maybe maybe
not obviously you know when you look at
it it's like hey yeah they did the same
thing put it that way out of where they
got it from you're not okay whatever um
but they did do the same thing but
here's here's what I really got from
that whole thing especially his video
how he did it he's like watch it yeah
what I did it really Illustrated that
that concept like how we talk about all
the time where when you when someone
says good like that it really stands out
now like you see that everywhere even if
you see the word good written on the on
a sign or something Joko sitting you see
I'm saying so it sticks out in your mind
just way more and again whether that
happened or not that's a weird word to
pick yeah that's not that's a weird word
to pick for the ad for the Nike yet it's
a little bit of a weird word about to
pick it's a little bit it's not a normal
word to pick you know in my opinion it's
a it's a good word to pick but anyways
nonetheless good that's it's all good
man you're the man I'm also good way to
support the just yell it feel kind of
had my back though didn't you Oh BJ oh
yeah what's up yeah and and it makes
sense too
yeah just the whole T I mean you know
but yeah I think that when you hear that
you I always hear all jock I just hear
you saying it you know even if I see the
word good in all caps in a regular
sentence but in a different context of
it'll remind me
it just sticks out like that anyway good
way support also is to subscribe on
iTunes and stitcher
if your Android Google playing you know
wherever you where we listen to your pod
your podcast just subscribe and don't
forget that there is the warrior kid
podcasts of which we recorded a couple
more today so we've got some fresh ones
out there I apologize for to everyone
for taking so long to get those out life
got the upper hand a little bit we back
but that's like yeah I had to get
default aggressive this weekend and this
crusher some of those yeah so warrior
kid podcast for your kids and for well
well really uncle Jake has lessons for
everybody also warrior kid there's a
warrior kid at Irish Oaks ranch calm
Aiden he's up there working hard and
he's making he's got a business he's
making soap tacos soap good yeah good
soap yeah and you can get that there
help help yourself
and you help yourself by stay staying
clean that's the idea
stay clean yeah the YouTube channel if
you want to see echoes legit video did
you post the the video that you just
made forgive the revenge revenge
I call it the revenge video you called a
forgive I have not posted that yet but
yes yes that's the YouTube video YouTube
channel which is called jockle podcast
it's a YouTube channel you can watch all
the YouTube videos on there and then you
can leave crazy comments from some
anonymous thing about all kinds of crazy
stuff which is fun sure whatever you
like also back back to working out I get
really okay on it calm on it the company
on it nope I got rings I told you
recently here's the thing about rings
again I said this before where you you
know you're always preaching about the
rings right it's like one of the what do
you call it the staples it's actually in
many ways considered to me to be the
first thing you could get if you if you
had one thing you could get you can get
rings and you could do really well with
them
yeah and I'm now reaping the benefits of
the Rings I got them brings on it rings
they're like they're actually pretty
dope
yeah we got to get good rings I always
tell everyone get wood rings not plastic
rings not metal rings get wood rings
because they absorb the sweat they yeah
anything else is slippery that's
horrible yeah so and my kids are you
know and they're adjustable you know I
mean I've only had on it rings so if
they're cool they're adjustable by
number and it's all the stuff so my kids
two years old and five years old like
they'll swing on them like they get
real creative with them anyway not yet
but I'll do the there's all these little
functional things anyway there's a lot
to be gained with the Rings I'm a
grandma believer of the Rings now and
now I would agree with you hundred
percent that that should be kind of the
first thing I think I used to say a
whole bar but you might as well get
rings can you blow up some and you can
do dips and you can do push-ups and you
can do muscle ups and you can do like
weird it's kind of squatting planking
all kinds of Stoya Appstore and cross in
here which I can't do by the way just in
case anyone gets the idea that I can do
an Iron Cross I'm here to tell you I
cannot even come close
yeah but here's the thing about rings
and pull-ups specifically this is why
it's better than a pull-up bar because
pull-ups pull-up bars coolants good
really good the drive had a pull-up bar
for a long time um but the Rings is like
yeah you can adjust for pull-ups and
then you can adjust them down so you can
do kind of like a rose situate you get
they're all adjustable you can do this
all day that's the overall yeah it
extended my workout literally by like
30% dang 30 yeah oh yeah cuz there's
other like I use them every single time
in exercise majorly
anyway anyway those are rings there's a
lot of other cool stuff on on it calm so
yeah man browse around see what up yeah
psychological warfare album we're
working on the next one I'm thinking
that the next one is not gonna come out
it's gonna come out right around
Christmas is my guess yeah so if you
have anything somebody wants one about
shopping compulsive how do I shop stop
compulsive shopping yeah I don't know if
I can tackle that one you know why I
have no compulsion to shop I don't even
like shopping only my own list
you don't know imma buy anything what
the demons of shopping yeah like I've
seen oh I will say I've seen it you see
people that buy things that they can't
really afford so I guess maybe we could
talk about it cuz ya know actually now
that I think about it I could talk about
that yeah we can we can we can put
together awesome so yeah psychological
warfare if you got little moments of
weakness you want to overcome I can talk
to you personally about that through
your iPhone Google Play iTunes is an mp3
file through your through your Android I
don't leave you all out through your
Samsung right sure equal-opportunity
platform device of all devices in every
scenario I'd say yeah and also you can
get that Jacque white day I'm on that
chain too there's a lot of trains in the
Chuckle situation supplementation
situation it's been hot yeah and well
when it was hot up in Maine at the camp
but how good did that so yeah you can
get that the the dry T as well if you
want to brew your own team now that
winter is coming you need to get the hot
tea so you can have a little little
warmth on your throat but that was never
really your thing right it wasn't but it
is now yeah yeah you make the adjustment
like oh yeah cuz sometimes sometimes you
just like it's a little chilly out a
little comfort yeah comfort that's what
you need all the time jungkook comfort
solid okay so then I also got some books
we got the way of the warrior kid and
marks mission this is for kids between
the ages of 4 and 84 because everybody
can get something yeah you got my
five-year-old fired up about getting the
job by the way yeah in the second book
mark who's a young character book wants
to get let's get a new bike yeah but he
needs money in order to get money guess
what you need you need a job son yeah
the job or sell some stuff or sell some
started job and so
that's what he has to do so yeah if you
want to give your kids a good book that
will teach them about discipline hard
work being kind you know but the
dichotomy of being strong it's all in
there
it's all in there surely you explain it
while you Uncle Jake whoever one of you
guys it's good how you explain it in
real simple terms and then you get this
kid mark especially the song talk about
the second right now where he's like he
kind of he overcame some stuff he's
super strong right now you know but
still a lot to learn so he understands
it and then at first he's like
questioning it then he starts to
understand any questions and then he
understands then he's fired up about
doing it you know I mean cuz he get but
it's really good and that's literally
how like the kid whoever you really in
my case I'm only reading to my daughter
by the way she's fine and I watch her
getting just as fired up as mark I'm a
business owner she's like oh my gosh
yeah oh she gets fired up pretty good
man really it's interesting to see the
little transition yeah I've get so much
good feedback anyways that's that way
the warrior kid and Mark's mission also
the discipline equals freedom Field
Manual which is solid which is solid
it's a good daily reminder it's not you
don't need to read that whole book every
day you can read one you can read three
pages and you can get yourself you know
you might have been veering off the path
like get yourself right back on the path
yeah
it's a good thing to read you could like
read that but read it page two pages
three pages every day it will would you
I would say this it will absolutely help
you if you read three pages a day yeah
that's a bold statement too I'm saying
this book a book this is enough this
isn't this isn't an exercise program
this isn't a supplement that you take
this isn't uh this isn't a treatment
that you get this is a book pages in a
book if you read them it's gonna help
you you know that's that's what my
statement is and I believe to be true
why because I read it I wrote the damn
thing and I still and it's helpful and
then we got extreme ownership which is
combat leadership who wrote it with my
brother lave babban and how to take the
principles that we learn in combat and
use them in in your business and life
and the
follow-on book to that the dichotomy of
leadership which I mentioned the word
dichotomy quite a bit Dean Lister says
it's my favorite word I'm not so sure
it's my favorite word I think my
favorite word is discipline but I don't
know if I have a favorite word anyways I
do talk about the dichotomy a lot
because the dichotomy is present in
everything that we do so if you want to
get this book it comes out to September
25th if you want to get the first dish
you should order it yesterday or right
now because well you don't want to miss
out on the first edition I got my first
copies I'm hold one right there there it
is so dichotomy leadership order it now
September 25th and it'll come to your
door speaking of leadership we had a
leadership consulting company called
echelon phone and we solve problems
through leadership it's me it's Lafe
it's JP Janel Dave Burke Flynn Cochran
we also got Mike's irelia on board we
got a couple new members joining the
team right now if you want us to come to
your company go to a chillon front comm
that's what we do
also the muster in San Francisco
California getting close to sold out we
probably have a little bit left right
now maybe by the time this podcast comes
out it might be sold out if you want to
come to the muster leadership event San
Francisco California October 17th and
18th all the other ones have sold out
this one is going to sell out too if you
want to come don't wait till the last
minute don't wait until I post on social
media that the musters sold out and then
call up and say can we please fit one
more people because we can't if we could
we wouldn't say it was sold out so just
just register now for the muster and for
current uniformed personnel military law
enforcement Border Patrol firefighters
paramedics first first responders we got
the roll call September 21st we just
opened up a few more seats I think we
opened up 50 more seats we've done that
twice now but it's gonna be I don't know
if we'll be able to do it again because
registrations gonna be closing soon
that is also registered at extreme
ownership calm
and of course now we have EF overwatch
where we are connecting SpecOps veterans
combat aviation veterans with companies
that need solid proficient leaders that
understand and can bring the attitude of
extreme ownership into your company if
you want to on either side if your vet
and you want to get in get look for a
job if you're someone that needs a
leader in your company go to EF over
watch.com to get in the game and if you
want to keep cruising with echo Charles
and me and you're not at one of those
events or you're not on one of those
events yet well then you can find us on
the interwebs on Twitter on Instagram
and on Facebook keepo hi echo is at echo
Charles and I am at Jocko willing and
lastly to everyone that is serving and
that has served in the US military
thanks to you and your families for
shielding us from evil and keeping us
free and to police law enforcement
correctional officers border patrol
firefighters paramedics other first
responders here at home thanks for being
vigilant and protecting us and our
families and to everyone else out there
keep learning keep striving and keep
trying to figure out where you can get
better and be better and it isn't easy
and it takes courage and it takes
strength and it takes discipline day
after day after day to get up and face
the unforgiving world and get after it
so until next time this is echo and
Jocko out